[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle émission qui parle avec
nous ce soir
mariah carey
emmanuel
julie delpy
le compagnon de gianni versace
une vraie mamie site
à l'appui ces nouveaux corps non
[Musique]
le jeune magna
m
mes filles chez les stars
et mon ami aux abris
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
et
est-ce que là est ce que la traduction
contzen
joseph et marie curie
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureuse de vous voir
thierry bien sûr que ça marche
ok c'est bon laurent huneault laurent
mauriac
j'ai connu des hauts mais ni people are
you come combien de gens sont avec vous
ici ce soir maria je ne sais pas 10 12
tennis énorme plus que ce dont on a
besoin et oui j'avais traduit qui avait
alors espéré single perfect et cindy
alors maria bonsoir zeroual comme vous
sortez ça va pas être possible
alors marien vous sortez votre premier
album depuis 2002 depuis charm bracelet
tu sais donc le grand come back de
mariah carey avec un album qui s'appelle
vies humaines six personnes mimi
l'émancipation de mini voilà alors min
en fête c'est votre surnom qui jusque là
étaient réservées à uniquement à des
gens très proches de voix
c'est ce que j'ai choisi le nom de mon
album tout le monde sait maintenant mais
ni mon surnom mais le fait d'appeler
votre album l'émancipation de mimi est
ce que ce n'est pas une façon de de
baisser un peu votre garde et de vous
rapprocher de vos fans maria je pense
que oui elle pense que j'ai pas dit une
connerie tu elle me fait un sourire doit
redevenir et un talent c'est un android
alors l'album s'appelle l'émancipation
de mini est le premier single s'appelle
it's like dat
sinon
à
[Musique]
m
l'écart est qu isabelle l'émancipation
de mimi alors you do est ce que est ce
que vous connaissez orlando en floride
c'était un homme un homme qui s'appelle
orlando vous connaissez pas c'est le
fruit d'un visa dedans vous ne
connaissez pas orlando je suis désolé je
ne le connais pas j'étais un français
enfin il est pas vraiment français
d'ailleurs il est connu et coire
l'andouille les spéciales 1 il a un
renard mort sur la tête d'eads fox belle
mort ce lac est un charmant et d'être
fox la lamelle or leur dos orlando il
veut voir le clip on a entendu votre
chanson mais orlando il veut qu'on voit
le clip alors vous regarder la caméra
avec le rouge et et vous dites
magnéto serge magnéto serge magnéto
l'annoncé par non non non non non
attention attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà il
cet extrait du nouvel album de mariah
carey qui s'appelle bien même si
passionnant et non suppression des
limites
alors alors votre père était afro
américain d'origine vénézuélienne
ce qui fait marié vous avez une enfance
assez difficile parce qu'à l'époque les
mariages mixtes étaient pas très bien
accepté dans la dans la société
américaine
je crois que c'est encore difficile à
gérer le mariage unique ce taux aux
etats unis c'est encore quelque chose
qui n'est pas facile surtout les enfants
alors votre maire a été rejetée par sa
propre famille parce qu'elle avait
épousé un un noir et le mariage était
très très difficile vos parents se sont
séparés ils ont divorcé quand vous aviez
trois ans et vous vous avez eu beaucoup
de mal à vivre votre votre identité
métisse non c'est pas ton identité c'est
la situation qui était difficile tant
que vous savez qui vous êtes en tant que
personne et bien on s'en sort c'est la
musique qui m'a permis d'en sortir donc
c'est une très bonne chose c'est c'est
un talon vous disiez que vous étiez trop
blanche pour être noir est trop noir
pour être blanche et vous avez du mal à
vous à vous situer c'est vrai enfin
c'est comme ça que les gens me
perçoivent dans une enfance assez
difficile finalement parce que
confrontées avec le le racisme la
voiture de vos parents a été détruite
devant chez vous votre chien a été
empoisonné et le pire encore c'était à
l'école c'est à dire que vous souffriez
beaucoup du racisme quotidiennement à
l'école c'est vrai vous savez j'ai
d'espoir j'espère que les gens aient
voulu que les gens changent parce que
c'est vraiment qu'on est obsédé par
l'apparence des gens qu'on ne se
préoccupe pas de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur et c'est ça qui compte
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui ça serait
plus facile pour une petite mariah carey
à l'école j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui ont des enfants métis et qui
finalement vivre les mêmes choses que
moi j'ai vécu c'est plus facile
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas 100%
arrangé j'écris actuellement un livre
pour enfants pour les enfants un mixte
un espèce de vade mecum et je construis
ça dira oui parce que vous c'était très
dur un jour vous amener une copine à la
maison elle voit votre père elle n'a
jamais vu un noir de sa vie et elle se
met à pleurer en voyant votre père il a
fallu que sa mère la ramène chez elle
parce que elle était vraiment victime
d'une d'une crise d'hystérie et vous
avez beaucoup souffert aussi cessé d
histoires terribles que vous avez vécu
un jour à l'école on vous demande de
dessiner votre famille et pour dessiner
votre père vous prenez un crayon noir et
à ce moment là tout le monde comprend
que votre père et noir et tout le monde
s'éloigne de vous je pensais pas qu'en
amérique il ya quelques années donc
quand vous étiez enfant il y avait
encore autant de racisme dans la vie
quotidienne je pensais que m avait moins
c'était quelque chose qui n'était pas
forcément très présent très ouvert où on
remarquait des petites choses et il
fallait les gérer à l'intérieur survivre
garder ça pour soi gérer les situations
mais on a tous nos difficultés je ne
vais pas dire là c'était moi moi j'ai eu
ces problèmes tout le monde a des
problèmes c'est le monde souffrent du
racisme d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est juste que quand on a un parent
blanc et un parent noir et bien on ne
comprend pas l'ethnie apparent ni
l'autre ne comprend vraiment la
situation de l'enfant voilà alors votre
mère était chanteuse d'opéra et
professeur de chant et et c'est elle qui
a découvert en fait votre votre talent
votre don pour paula pour la chanson
quand vous étiez petit vous y mettiez
ses vocalises magnétophone
rappelez vous auriez magnétophone
parfois vous corrigiez même ces fausses
notes c'est vrai ça une somme gelée
corriger une fois c'est ce qu'elle a
raconté
ah ah ah les as du cnes pers
ok mais ça me rappelle le nex nex nex la
semaine prochaine bon show quand vous
avez votre votre diplôme de change est
parti de la maison pour aller tenter
votre chance et à new york c'est ça oui
en gros oui et alors là vous faites des
petits boulots pendant la journée
vous êtes serveuse et vestiaire vous
êtes hôtesses et la nuit vous fait des
maquettes des maquettes de chansons
j'ai jusqu'au jour où quelqu'un donne
une de vos maquettes à tommy mottola qui
à l'époque était le grand patron de sony
qui a donné la maquette à tony mottola
c'était pas une grande chanteuse assez m
je suis un peu perdue parce que vous
vous me posez des questions sérieuses et
lui me parle de fruits légumes alors je
ne saurais le dire est ce que ma
candidature
comparé de l'émancipation des mini
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici non mais moi
donc brenda questa a donné la démo riehl
à tony mottola qui lui a trouvé ça
formidable qui vous a signé un contraste
en compte de fait quoi en fait j'avais
un accord avec les warner brothers qui
qui était sur le point d'être signé et
je n'ai presque pas été à la fête à
laquelle brenda a donné la démo et
finalement j'y suis allé tout s'est bien
passé et ça m'a permis finalement
d'écrire mes propres chansons
j'avais plus d'un label qui
s'intéressait à moi donc je pouvais dire
aux gens non vous pouvez pas me forcer à
faire ce que je ne veux pas faire don
comme menacée
non
millions d'albums
en 40 millions d'albums vendus
[Applaudissements]
g j'ai dit 140 millions d'albums vendus
il a un autre fils à 130 millions cherry
ne faut pas croire tout ce qu'on dit ça
c'est vous it's you oui ça c'est bon 27
mars 70 c'est bon ça c'est moi j'étais
britney spears
ils sont 130 millions vérité schiste
donc à 24 ans je vais vous étonner
mottola 3000 personnes au mariage et
qu'est ce qui se passe après pourquoi
dans ce couvent ou sombrer dans la
dépression vous dit
les limites étaient dépassées c'était le
gouffre pourquoi parce que c'était une
relation très difficile d'être avec
quelqu'un qui avait le double méninges
qui était le directeur de mirabel dont
le meilleur ami et l'avocat et dans tous
les arts sont des gens qui travaillent
pour lui c'est pas très drôle c'est
c'était plutôt terne et maussade
est-ce qu'à l'époque on a dit que vous
aviez des problèmes de drogue c'est vrai
ça aurait été plutôt bien d'avoir de la
drogue pour supporter tout ça vous avez
pensé à vous suicider à l'époque
bon c'est parce que vous savez c'était
quand même une situation dans laquelle
j'étais très malheureuse et c'est pour
ça que je suis parti que j'ai quitté
cette situation parce qu'elle ne me
convenait pas après vous trouvé
l'énergie de vous en sortirez vous vous
réfugiez chercher votre mère ce qui est
très symbolique derrière vous vous vous
réfugiez dans la maison que vous aviez
offert à votre mère avec votre premier
katché oui c'est vrai
et là quand vous arrivez chez votre mère
vous vous effondrez sur le carrelage de
la cuisine elle appelle une ambulance et
on vous amène l'hôpital pendant qu'elle
pendant quelques temps j'étais vraiment
à bout
j'étais à bout et quand vous avez trouvé
l'énergie de revenir après vous savez
j'avais besoin de repos et aujourd'hui
je me dis que finalement c'était une
bonne chose il faut savoir quand
s'arrêter quand se reposer et si je
n'avais pas craqué je ne sais pas ce qui
aurait pu se produire
je ne sais pas quel aurait été le
résultat donc quelque part ça a été une
bonne chose un mal pour un bien
je pense qu'aujourd'hui je produis de
meilleur album de ma carrière et
finalement tout ce qu'on une traverse
est qu'on survit vous rend plus fort
et c'est mon objectif moi j'essaye de de
nourrir ma musique de tout ce que j'ai
vécu et d'essayer de t'en sortir une
meilleure personne personne plus forte
et sentimentalement comment ça va
maintenant
sentimentalement les gens viennent pas
vers moi comme si j'étais quelqu'un
d'autre parce qu'il y a des gars du port
et c'est difficile d'entrer en contact
avec moi et et je suis toujours entouré
d'une foule mais ça fait partie comme
mode c'est comme ça vous vous pensez que
vous pensez que vous fait peur aux
hommes un peu maria j'espère que non
mais peut-être que oui peut-être que oui
vous allez rester longtemps à paris
offre encore une petite bière et puis je
vous parle voilà le des patines
européenne tu finis quand j'aime venir
ici
jn 1 qui m'attend c'est vrai on va en
allemagne ce soir vous partez ce centre
mathorel il arrive à porte de la
chapelle et là il ya des bus pour
l'allemagne qui rit c'est jamais rappelé
aux jurés de but c'est un but pour
l'allemagne
ça m'est égal comment j'y arrive disons
que j'ai c'est s'il le faut je tiendrai
1832 la chatte est écrit nous ça se
passe est ce que vous êtes une diva je
suppose on arrête à une faute était
question donc gtoi être une diva on va
vérifier interview diva alors on va voir
mariah carey si vous êtes une diva
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé que
votre chambre d'hôtel soit tapissé de
fleurs non est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait voyager votre chien en business
class entre new york et los angeles pour
lui faire un bisou
il est rose rang est d'accord je dois
l'emmener dans un avion privé
donc ce n'est pas vraiment d'histoire et
et mon chien s'appelle djak et djack est
très célèbre
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu on
ouvre un magasin spécialement pour vous
non mais ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
rentre dans un magasin les gens savent
que je vais dépenser de l'argent et donc
s'en sortir tout le monde je leur
demande pas de le faire et en général je
ne suis pas là très tôt et j'arrivais un
petit peu en fin de journée donc ils
sont sur le point de fermer mais s'ils
savent que je vais dépenser des sous ils
restent ouverts c'est du bon sens
commercial
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu'un de
vos fans se brosse les dents avant de
vous embrasser non
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu'on
parce que vos disques dans une boîte de
nuit où vous allez danser
j'aime entendre ce que font d'autres
gens en discothèque
est-ce que vous avez déjà réserver
toutes les tables d'un restaurant pour
pouvoir dîner tranquillement
mais peut-être est-ce que vous avez déjà
exigé d'avoir une piscine dans votre
loge c'est excellent pour les cheveux et
le maquillage savez est-ce que vous avez
déjà exigé de l'eau minérale pour vous
laver les cheveux
non non est-ce que vous avez exigé que
votre entourage voit votre film glitter
ségalou annonce est une bonne question
sa présence
tiens
il ya une tradition dans cette émission
c'est que tous les invités tirer une
carte melli
carte confession vous devez qu'on fait
c'est quelque chose que vous avez sur le
coeur
j'ai vraiment je me pose des questions
politiques j'ai regardé des cassettes du
show et c'est pour ça que je suis venu
ce soir
donc en fait il m'impressionne beaucoup
il
il me rend très nerveuse
à
merci merci beaucoup d'un cube en commun
[Musique]
mais
et
[Musique]
jacques gaye henri emmanuelli
et
bonsoir bonsoir de vous recevoir henry
alors vous êtes député ps président du
conseil général des landes partisans du
non pardon partisans du mineur n'a pas
donc je crois qu'on apprenne de cravate
on va changer la cre a bien compris
votre cravate en riant va la changer
l'ignoble on me dit elle est ignoble ce
qui peut changer de travail
enfin c'est trop tard alors on est là
non moi je moi je la trouve pas mal à
l'elysée il insiste on continue d'accord
bien alors donc on va parler du
référendum évidemment au sujet de
l'europe le 29 mai alors il ya eu un
vote au ps pour savoir s'il fallait
voter oui ou non et le résultat bat c
oui à 59% donc en bonne logique
excusez moi de vous dire aussi crûment
henry mais vous devriez la ferme est en
bonne logique oui mais d'ajouter cela
j'ai un petit problème c'est que moi je
considère que certain nombre de choses
se sont passées depuis et qui font que
je ne peux pas garder le silence
donc vous refusez les consignes de
silence imposée par françois hollande
vous ne respectez pas là la discipline
du parti
mais pourtant quand même les 59 % c'est
un vote démocratique wajir appartement
où il ya 59 %
c'est quand vous devez respecter la
démocratie c'est sûr c est ce qui je
pense aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
les militants socialistes il ya des
millions d'électeurs socialistes et moi
je pense que le 29 mai on s'apercevra
que dans leur immense majorité les
électeurs socialistes eux auront voté
non vous avez effectivement une lettre
ouverte aux adhérents du ps annonçant le
lancement de la campagne pour un non
socialiste pour vous le oui c'est une
erreur historique car il ne prend pas en
compte la dimension sociale de l'europe
cherche que vous dites en gros c'est que
si on vote oui on va aligner l'europe
sur le libéralisme anglo-saxon en gros
et qu'on va perdre cette notion de de
filet social qui fait la particularité
de leur wii avait avec surtout un sujet
qui me paraît très grave et qui va
devenir le sujet dominant dans les mois
les années qui viennent qui est celui de
l'emploi et du salariat l'europe
c'est-à-dire la question des
délocalisations
je pense qu en ne se préoccupant pas de
ce sujet la social démocratie européenne
comme est une erreur historique parce
que des millions de femmes et d'hommes
vont se retrouver dans la précarité au
chômage ou bien avec des salaires en
baisse et que ça c'est au ouvrir une
voie royale à l'extrême droite sur ce
vieux continent qui malheureusement à un
essai dans pour vous votez oui c'est
accepter la dérive libérale de l'europe
cesser d'accepter la dérive libérale
pour moi voter non c'est pas voté contre
l'europe je suis européen
je fais partie de ceux qui ont converti
le parti socialiste au fédéralisme
européen
mais je pense qu'on peut être pour
l'europe et contre ce traité un petit
peu comme en france on a pu être contre
la constitution 58 sans être contre la
république
alors on va essayer de nous faire croire
le contraire on va nous dire si vous
êtes contre le traité c'est que vous
êtes contre l'europe non voilà donc 11
mars sur france bleu gascogne vous avez
quand même sorti votre faute phrase la
caf et le has a fait le tour du pays
assez rapidement vous avez dit la
majorité du parti n'est pas infaillible
tir 27 59% pour le oui c'est pas pour ça
qu'ils ont raison et alors vous avez
effectivement donné deux preuves de ce
que vous ce que vous annonciez vous avez
dit en 1940
la majorité des socialistes à voter les
pleins pouvoirs vous avez dit laval en
fait c'est péta bon et pendant la guerre
d'algérie la majorité socialiste était
d'accord pour envoyer le le contingent
en algérie pour garder l'algérie
française voilà j'ai donné deux exemples
pour montrer que même quand on est
majoritaire n'a pas forcément raison
ouais et à partir de là on a construit
un procès d'intention par analogie on a
dit puisqu'il a dit ça ça veut dire
qu'il traite ceux qui vont voter pour le
oui
n'est ce pas de pétainiste alors ça fait
quand même beaucoup ça s'appelle une
association d'idées ça s'appelle un
raisonnement par analogie 1 c'est pas
très correct oui car il ne m'a pas
traversé l'esprit que ceux qui vont
voter oui n'est ce pas aurait donné les
pleins pouvoirs au maréchal fait
notamment face à vous est peut-être pas
traversé l'esprit mais quand même c'est
vrai quand on dit ceux qui ont résisté
sont passés à la postérité ceux qui ont
pas résisté à l'époque ont été couverts
d'opprobre
c'est à dire quand même qu'aujourd'hui
excusez moi mais bon les choses veut
dire ce qu'elle veut le dire dire
qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout
voter oui c'est un peu être comme ces
députés socialistes qui voient que les
pleins pouvoirs à pétain ou guy mollet
qui envoie le bon d'argent en algérie
s'il s'agit pas de la guerre quand même
là il s'agit de voter pour un traité oui
moi je veux bien qu'après on ait tiré
n'est ce pas les chauffer leur faire
dire ce qu'elles veulent pas dit non
mais vous saviez bien en disant ça quand
même c'était un petit peu que vous avez
fait comme si les gens du oui était un
peu des collabos quand même vous avez
henry ouais pourquoi permis si la
polémique et c'est pourquoi pas déjà
c'est votre côté sud oues et la
polémique chez les investisseurs
l'éloquence et la polémique je ne
polémique pas avec les socialistes
moi je fais campagne non pas dans le
parti mais dans le pays
oui et je dis aux socialistes nous votez
pas pour ceux traités pour un certain
nombre de réseaux un françois hollande
le patron du ps a parlé de dérapage
inadmissible
il a dit qu'il faisait appel aux peurs
aux frilosités aux mensonges aux
amalgames et pas l'intelligence aux
robes écouter en matière d'intelligence
comme je ne suis pas un spécialiste je
laisse les autres ceux annoncés n'est ce
pas il ay la vie c'est pas en disant non
que l'europe va devenir socialiste c'est
à dire que il vous donne pas
l'impression un peu de baisser les bras
finalement d'être un peu finalement bon
il ya comme une fatalité la dérive
libérale de l'europe d'une certaine
façon on dirait que je ne sais pas si en
disant non l'europe va devenir
socialiste mais je suis sûr qu'en disant
oui elle n'a aucune chance de l'être
pas mal alors le problème c'est que
votre copain mélenchon là jean luc
mélenchon votre copain du nouveau monde
là votre courant le nouveau monde
alors oui vous êtes totalement
désapprouvé je comprends pas parce que
lui il est pour le nom aussi mélenchon
il vous a complètement laissé tomber il
a dit on va mettre le nouveau monde
notre mouvement commun en sommeil
jusqu'au 29 mai qu'est ce qui s'est
passé n'est pas bien ce jeu là pro mais
c'est pas bien du tout les soirs et
maintenant il n'est pas sur votre ligne
app store
ça me fait rire c'est que même à
l'intérieur du nom à l'interdît non
agrément corps des sous groupes il ya
des jurés ont bougé aussi l'embrouillé
c'est important pour le non
mélenchon non mais c'est pas comme vous
il vous a totalement désapprouver il
veut plus faire le nouveau mandat nous
en riz je pense qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
françaises et français qui se couchent
le soir un adenium comme problème majeur
de savoir ce que ap
mais l'addition et mahumane yushu
pourquoi les mecs du nom commence à la
bourre quand même normal qu'on se pose
des questions quant à la bourre on vous
demande de voter non ya pas un risque de
schisme de scission ps avec cette
histoire
il ya un vrai problème d'orientation
politique entre ce que moi j'ai appelé
les sociaux libéraux qui ont fait des
gens qui acceptent cette logique du
capitalisme financier ou l'actionnaire
lesparre en caisse et où le salarié
trinque on est quand même dans une
europe où les dividendes augmentent 23
plus vite que les salaires
et ça fait gros problème en ce moment
dans notre pays comme vous le savez ils
sont pas contents d'être pas content
parce que le pouvoir d'achat a reculé a
dit qu'il allait faire
oui mais comme on sait que quand
raffarin dit quelque chose en général
c'est pas suivies d'effet c'est penser à
mon avis c'est une attitude c'est pas
présider f k positive attitude
si c'est pour dire du mal de l attendait
mélenchon il paraît que syfy je retire
je retire et le champ parce que je vais
encore un procès en sorcellerie
mais mélenchon il part actif et des
meetings avec les communistes il sera
viré du ps vient tout seul ce qu'a dit
hollande est ce que vous n'avez pas peur
d'être viré en rive ça n'est pas sérieux
henry si vous virez moi j'ai peur d'être
viré par l'histoire mais par yens 2,1
oui leur est lancé non je ne m'en fous
pas parce que je pense que dire qu'on
s'en fout ce serait être grisant penser
que l'opinion des mois je respecte tout
le monde
simplement je pense que c'est ma
responsabilité est peut-être pas énorme
mais elle existe le sentiment d'être
comme de gaulle quand il est parti à
londres en 40
je n'irai pas jusque là quand même un
peu mais je pense en revanche que être
socialiste c'est d'abord être résistant
rebelles
ce n'est pas s'accommoder de l'ordre
insistant l'ordre établi sur tout ça
vous a rien rapporté cette affaire parce
que donc tout le monde nous est tombé
dessus et mêmes les magazines comme le
point le nouvel observateur vous met en
baisse à cause de votre phrase là je
sens que ça va
handicapé ma nuit ma prochaine nuit bien
y avoir dans ce qui est terrible c'est
l'ump alors l'ump à une porte parole qui
s'appelle valérie pécresse alors un a
dit emmanuel il marche sur les
plates-bandes de monsieur le pen bonza
bon et d'une
mais après là où ça devient quand même
beaucoup plus grave pour vous elle parle
de propos inqualifiables
elle parle de réécriture de l'histoire
et elle dit que la réécriture de
l'histoire a toujours été larmes des
extrémistes alors vous avez pas réécrit
l'histoire c'est nous c'est bien quand
même une majorité de députés socialistes
a bien voté les pleins pouvoirs à pétain
c'est vrai ça la majorité de ces fléaux
à l'époque a voté les pleins sefyu sefyu
de guy mollet a bien envoyé le
contingent en algérie mais on va les
amarres écrit l'histoire et madame
pécresse me paraît d'une inculture
historique assez grande
j'ai d'ailleurs fait passer un mot au
président l'assemblée à debré à l'écouté
si elle pense que le pen n'était pas
pour vichy et n'était pas jerry
française il faudra changer de
porte-parole 1
j'ai d'ailleurs reçu un mail assez
intéressant d'un professeur de médecine
il leur a adressé en disant je vote pour
de gaulle depuis pour les gaullistes
depuis 20 ans 1
mais si vous ne changez pas cette dame
qui manifestement ne comprend rien
quoique la prochaine fois j'irai voir
ailleurs c'est à dire que c'est vrai
qu'elle vous compare un peu elle dit que
fait la réécriture de l'histoire c'est
grave en france quand on parle de
réécriture de l'histoire on pense aux
négationnistes on pense à forissier qui
existe c'est quand même un qui est grave
c'est de voter oui à ce traité et
pourquoi bon parce que ce traité je
déconne mais pour une fois qu'il était
sérieux mais que son truc tombe viennent
à propos ouais ouais mais j'arrive je
pose la question mais je n'arrive pas à
m'intéresser à la réponse mais c'est
personnel
ça veut dire quoi l'euro ça veut dire
que dire que les enjeux de ces votes et
je m'en faisais le sujet vous paraît
léger
inintéressant non ça veut dire que je ne
comprends pas et on en reparlera tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que c'est chaud en ce
moment au ps le 8 mars à guéret dans la
creuse
françois hollande a été victime d'une
bataille de boules de neige
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient une
manifestation il y avait une
manifestation de soutien aux services
publics et françois hollande a été
victime de deux jus de boules de neige
et la bataille de mélenchon un soir il
fabius a dit de mélenchon et fabius a
dit on le sentait venir quand même nom
mais quand même c'est choquant attaqué
le premier secrétaire a la boule de
neige sera le doigt de l'habitat je vais
donc fabius a été obligé de faire fabius
étaient obligés de faire son
autocritique au bureau national
alors si c'est quand même un bon moi je
n'apprécie pas qu'on ait jeté des boules
de neige vous étiez quoi sur françois
hollande qui est un homme et j'ai estimé
que je respecte pas mal parce que ce
qu'ils ont fait ça trompe tutor voilà
bon tuteur oui bon ans d'histoire et
j'ai dit ça sans tuteur il ya un truc ya
un truc est ce qu'on va vous on comprend
encore bon vous êtes pour le non et tout
parce que vous êtes quand même très à
gauche mais pas du parti socialiste mais
un type comme fabius qui lui est quand
même série ça fait combien d'années que
vous le supportez ça fait depuis 92 ça
fait oui d'années on a changé la
carabine et je savais qu'il était
admirable s'habille en noir sa forme et
vous on comprend pas ce que bon vous
êtes comme toujours très à gauche du ps
je suis pas père est très à gauche mais
fabius par exemple lui c'est vrai que
c'est plus bizarre quand même un titre
qui a toujours était quand même très
social libéral pourquoi il est pour le
nom penser que c'est pour se positionner
pour la présidentielle de 2007
je sentais venir l'empoisonnement de la
présidentielle dans ce pays depuis cinq
ans on peut plus parler de rien ce
encore eu si tôt ça tourne à la
présidentielle
1 avant quand j'étais petit c'était le
lait qui tournait maintenant c'est une
discussion politique qui tourne à la
présidentielle en permanence la grande
quand même moi je ne souhaite pas qu'on
pollue ce débat important pour les
français pour l'europe parce que ça
allait engager pour 30 ou 50 ans 1
n'est ce pas avec le choix du candidat
on fera le choix du candidat l'année
prochaine et je n'ai qu'une certitude
c'est que des candidats il y en aura
trop doit y aura pas besoin de faire
c'est pas candidat vous coûter en 95 et
vous avez été candidat à la candidature
peut-être qu'après cette émission si
elle a un audimat suffisant on dirait
bien tiré mais pour l'instant je
m'occupe de l'europe
vous êtes libre en fête par rapport à la
présidentielle
nous avons plus de chance on aime
beaucoup j'ai pensé d'acheter un peu
votre hymne en ce moment j'ai pensé j'y
ai pensé
il est libre max 1 c'est un peu les
portes du pénitencier pour rien mais ce
que j'aimerais si pour expliquer mais on
se reverra j'en suis sûr mardi pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai beaucoup auraient quoi le
roi cette europe n'est pas démocratique
je voudrais pouvoir expliquer aussi
pourquoi elle et pas sociale et ce sont
ces raisons de fond qui me pousse à dire
voter non ne rejetez pas l'europe mais
n'acceptez pas l'europe quand on veut
vous vendre à toute force en mélangeant
votre attachement à l'europe avec une
politique de droite c'est vrai que cette
semaine j'ai lu barroso là le patron de
l'europe la télé là il agressif pépère
il est agressif et plus alors il est
passé à savoir il a dit chirac j'en vois
trois heures j'ai lettre à monsieur
chirac pour lui d'y écouter je comprends
pas chaque fois que vous dit quelque
chose monsieur vient commissaire
européen qui dit le contraire
j'ai fait une lettre pour lui demander
quand même s'ils pensaient pas que la
france était sérieusement de quitter
alors attendez en 92 étiez pour
maastricht absolument y avait des gens
avec enthousiasme il y avait des gens
qui en 92 disait attention si on fait
l'europe si on vote oui à maastricht on
va se retrouver avec des barroso qui
vont nous dire ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui on y est donc vous êtes
trompés et trompé en 80 ans et sa non se
perdre et 100 kg mitterrand patronat
rentré j'ai pas sentiment à l'époque il
s'agissait de faire l'euro on prête pas
que l'euro existe même s'il est mal
gérée si c'est difficile il est très mal
géré monsieur trichet aujourd'hui fait
une politique qui nous coûte à peu près
7 points de croissance depuis 2000 et
des millions de chômeurs pourquoi parce
qu'on a une route trop élevé par rapport
au dollar
même si la droite votent non mais y
avait plein de gens avaient peur non il
y avait plein de gens à l'époque qui
disaient il va y avoir des barroso qui
vont nous dire ce qu'il faut faire et
aujourd'hui vous dit-il terre sinon
l'avons dit ce que je risque de villiers
dix ans 80 ans aurait jamais pu faire un
coup tu deviennes ici de vérifier les
européens qui vont diriger la france
non je vous dit ce que disent les autres
à l'époque je ne dis pas ça et vous le
savez très bien et n'hésitez pas vous ne
le ferez pas dit t'es lourdingue mais
oui c'est vrai qu'à un moment
bon je suis convaincu je vais voter non
oui nous sommes pour que j'arrête quand
on connaît encore je fais pas n'importe
qui sans rien apporter de bon alors
sérieusement est-ce que l'europe n'ait
pas déjà dépassé finalement n'est ce pas
un joueur mais pas une pierre face à la
mondialisation est ce que l'europe n'ait
pas déjà dépassé non je disais tout à
l'heure par face aux délocalisations 1
je pense que l'europe va devoir se
protéger à avoir un tarif extérieur
commun la lave est rodée par
l'abandonner ensuite les états unis le
fond je vois pas pourquoi l'europe ne
pourrait pas le faire alors ça veut pas
dire qu'il faille faire du
protectionnisme mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut avoir un colt dans la botte pour
pouvoir éventuellement se défendre il y
a des choses à faire dans le sens du
progressisme et dans le sens d'une
europe
umanis est ce qu'on veut nous fabriquer
c'est une europe anglo saxon est
conservatrice et moi je suis socialiste
alors me dit mais il faut quitter le
parti où il faut plus laide mais je peux
pas tirer
j'ai trois milliards de cellules comme
com vous avait 3 milliards avec un noyau
dans chaque cellule
elles sont tous socialistes alors on va
faire une interview référendum
[Musique]
alors henri emmanuelli
vous allez répondre par oui ou par non
yes est ce que vous êtes pour le projet
de constitution européenne oui ou non
non est ce que vous êtes pour la turquie
dans la communauté européenne oui ou non
mais je suis entre les deux noms mais
rld bon mais je préfère dire oui non est
ce que vous êtes pour françois hollande
comme candidat de la gauche en 2007
oui non myriam est ce que vous êtes pour
une candidature ségolène royal à la
présidence oui non oui ouais il veut me
fâcher avec tout les socialisme non si
j'achète ici mines non je suis pas il
révèle que vous êtes pour le retour de
lionel jospin en 2007 oui ça continue
si j'aurais su ben je serais venu à
d'armure
est ce que vous êtes pour 25 la première
dame de france
oui non oui est-ce que vous rêvez d'être
président non est ce que vous êtes pour
une loi contre l'homophobie contre oui
est ce que vous êtes pour la chute de
fidel castro
oui est ce que vous êtes pour la fin du
nucléaire en france non est ce que vous
êtes pour la ferme célébrités 2
non est ce que vous êtes pour le string
programme oui est ce que vous êtes pour
le vote par internet
oui est ce que vous êtes pour une
cigarette après manger oui non est ce
que vous êtes pour lyon champion de
france cette saison
oui non oui oui pourquoi pas est ce que
vous êtes pour que je vous tire les
sourcils pour voir si c'est des vrais
oui
et
merci on est bien si roche moi j'écoute
j'avais espéré mieux que les sourcils
mais je m'en contenterai on va peut-être
vous arrivez mieux mais mines méline je
dois répondre en tournant le dos à la
caméra mais c'est pas possible j'ai pas
de cheveux derrière elle est où la
caméra elle est là bon alors un autre
vélo est ce que vous êtes content d'être
venu ce soir est ce que vous pensez que
votre message va mieux passé henry je
pense que tout le monde a compris
à une exception près peut-être s'ils
auront mais qui dormait mais est ce que
tu peux juste dire chaussée au moins
j
oi oi oi oi
tav à julie
alors en fait je crois que je crois que
je vais voter comme vous me direz de
voter s'ils voulaient que je vote oui ou
non on dit moi parce que quand je vous
vois je fais tout ce que vous voulez je
revoterai je vous dirai tout à l'heure
avant alors julie tout le monde parle de
vous en france mais une presse
incroyable pour votre nouveau film qui
s'appelle de force n 7
pareille aux usa you are de toko veut
tarn diot liddell paille john rigas
oscars pour meilleur scénario pour
before sunset votre film le chouchou des
critiques ça va du village voice au los
angeles times et le magazine américain
première vous a sélectionné parmi les
comédiens les plus admirables de l'année
j'ai beaucoup de chance cette année en
pas de la chance ne s'est pas une
ennemie racle ou non non non j'ai eu
beaucoup de changer le film a été très
appréciée before sunset et c'est vrai
que la critique américaine surtout à
vraiment encore utile mais quoi ouais
ouais ils l'ont pris c'est devenu le
film préféré de la critique américaine
voilà alors maintenant que vous êtes une
star américaine de passage en france est
ce que vous allez être fait chevalier
des arts et lettres comme toutes les
stars américaines qui viennent à paris
je vais recevoir un petit truc à ne pas
donner à tout donner un stallone ils ont
donné un des canadiens j'ai vu ça
l'écrivain américain dira-t-il gens qui
se précipitent pour lui accrochée à moi
je suis candidat pour l'épingler gens
bien ces mecs du nouveau monde
alors vous avez le privilège d'assister
donc aux 2 1 aux oscars aux césar dans
votre vie c'est lequel le plus chiant le
plus chiant mais écoutez les césars ça
fait très très longtemps je me souviens
pas très bien les oscars je me suis pas
fait chier du tout en tout cas c'est sûr
mais bon qu'est ce que vous auriez dit
si vous avez gagné vous avez préparé un
petit truc je suis super rien préparé à
peu près sûr de pas gagné c'était un peu
si vous avez une phrase de billy wilder
que j'adore sur les sur les prix les
prix et les décorations c'est comme les
hémorroïdes n'importe quel trou du cul
finir un jour par en avoir
voilà voilà
vous auriez pu dire ça certains savaient
très bien
patrice serait pas très bien passé 10
mois alors aux oscars c'est ça faisait
pas drôle de voir gérard jugnot à côté
de clint eastwood
il n'était pas exactement à côté de lui
1 mais non j'ai vu gérard jugnot j'ai
dit bonjour il m'a fait moi il n'y a pas
l'habitude que les jolies femmes ne
disent bonjour ya pas longtemps qu'ils
connaissaient pas mais non mais on s'est
croisés avant tout ça il a trahi ma
maman tout ça pour rien disait bonjour
mais il croyait que je le connaissais
pas il suit pas les gens tout d'un coup
se disent peut-être que je j'ai pas que
je vous aviez cette robe dos car non non
j'allais bien soleil j'aime beaucoup
cette fois c'est le même fabricant c'est
une adresse moi qui fait sage et
l'arrière 2-1 ah oui et brillant si vous
êtes déjà perdu le diplôme qu'on vous a
remis aux oscars en fait je suis très
bordélique et personne qui fait le
ménage chez moi arrange les choses et
une fois que ces rangées je trouve plus
jamais donc bon c'est pas grave je vais
le retrouver un évident éventuellement
donc voilà alors ce film qui recueille
temps de louhans c'est un film qui
s'appelle before sunset donc de richard
linklater avec ifan hawk et vous il est
sorti en france depuis mercredi
alors c'est la suite de before sunrise
il faut dire quelque chose facile et du
before sunrise envoyez pas une vraie
suite c'est plus une continuation ouais
il est trop fort lui parce qu'on est
passés ensemble un déjà à la bombarde
aux havrais quoi que si vous avez fait
ensemble
non non non non c'est parfait l'europe
pas tout vous dire
dans une autre émission tous les deux
déjà dit drague il endort les gonzesses
avions fait le grand journal c'est pas
grave personne regarde
à vous étiez déjà tous les deux c'est
marrant mais en fait la promo groupé
quoi elle dit du bien de son film dit
non à l'europe
si c'est ça c'est ça les médias modernes
alors dans before sunrise qui est sorti
en 95
les deux héros c'est à dire vous et y
fallot c'est une rencontre d'une nuit
quoi puis après ils séparés en se
faisant la promesse de se revoir
six mois plus tard voilà au même endroit
mais elle empêcher n'est pas venue voilà
ça c'est vrai en fait là c'est la suite
est en fait ils se retrouvent ils seront
tous parce que lui a écrit un livre où
il raconte sa nuit neuf ans après il est
dans une librairie is in ses bouquins et
l arrivée voilà il se retrouvait là le
film et en temps réel ils vont passer 90
minutes elle l'a dit ça chez denisot non
et comment elles avaient péché henry
enfin comment elle était bien content il
est fou comment il était à domicile on a
écrit le scénario le réalisateur
on a écrit lulz non non mais justement
je vais savoir si si elle avait aussi
bien vendu le film che c'est denisot
henry a l'air de dire à mon avis mieux
ici veut que je vois que l'on génère pas
revoter pour toi pour me faire plaisir
donc alors ils passent 90 minutes
ensemble donc en temps réel il parle de
tout de rien et surtout de la question
de l'amour romantique est ce que l'amour
résiste au quotidien est ce que l'amour
n'est pas dans le dans la tente de
lotois l'impossibilité l'amour paternel
de l'auron résistera au temps
merci héritant du bois quelque chose
déjà fait énormément à quoi ça ressemble
je vais regarder votre caméra et vous
allez dire magnéto serge magnéto serge
non mais attends c'est pas un truc de
sado maso qui peut lui parler
d'ailleurs serge de ses maîtresses du
lit alors on fait le plus charmant parce
que sinon il en sera pas le magnéto je
connais des désordres autrement à nancy
et en même temps ça fait un peu mal à
aller serge laborde
on
verbatim france
[Musique]
g
itunes
précise
[Musique]
nous sommes à la tâche
nous sommes tranquilles
oui
voilà la recette d'un richard linklater
avec piano et julie delpy
il me craint vite et ce soir voilà alors
j'imagine qu'après il y aura un
troisième un troisième épisode after
sunset on conserve 27 ou non we go crazy
non je ne sais pas
on n'a pas prévu ça le second l'a fait
parce qu'on avait vraiment envie de
retravailler ensemble on a eu du mal à
trouver de l'argent tout ça pour le
faire mine de rien enfin ça a été après
le film a eu du succès mais a priori
faire une suite un film indépendant
ouais c'est spécial quoi vous avez
déclaré c'est difficile parce qu'il
fallait que tout ça sonne juste et
surtout pas cliché façon amélie poulain
et c'est vrai que amélie poulain ses
tresses les chefs et non mais stylisé
pour ça que j'ai dit je dis que c'était
pas utilisé à paris pastis et stylisé ça
peut être très bien ça peut être un
américain mary bah oui laure manadou si
ça peut être très bien mais là c'était
panama utiliser un autre style de paris
plus réel attendez moi je moi j'apprécie
votre côté atypique après après godard
carax kislov ce qui vous est parti aux
états unis
faire une école de cinéma je veux dire
c'est quand même une fille courageuse
que vous avez passé tout petit tout
petit bien je vois ses parents étaient
déjà dans le métier folie aux siens mais
c'est vrai que vous avez refusé de
n'être que qu'actrice près ce que vous
dites quand on est acteur actrice on vit
du désir de l'autre et finalement on ne
s'appartient pas à quoi non il ya
quelque chose qui me sonia il ya quelque
chose qui était très angoissant d'être
juste acteurs pour moi mais j'aime
beaucoup être actrice mais il faut que
je fasse d'autre chose je peux pas
attendre que le téléphone sonne
ouais alors ce que vous avez fait vous
avez fait ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
face nord en hiver si vous êtes parti
tout seul aux états unis tout ça et
finalement ça vous a pas si mal réussi
comme quoi voyez hein
comme quoi finalement une attitude un
petit peu comme ça un petit peu hautaine
un petit peu différent c'était pas
vraiment autant je suis parti de france
parce qu'on proposait rien 20 faut dire
que vous avez fait chier tout le monde
quand même
non non attendez j'ai pas fais chier
tout le monde j'ai fait chier on m'a
fait chier bordel de merde jeunes canton
comme ça on m'a fait chier c'est ça
attendez il faudrait pas retourner les
choses dans l'autre
on m'a fait chier non m'a fait chier je
me suis cassé ses toiles à tes parents
tous les cas vous avez réussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous revenez pratiquement
oscarisé avec un film dans toute la
presse parle mais voilà c'est tout alors
oui dit j'adore ma vie oui j'aimais
votre vie finalement oui mais après j
arrive à ça et c'est comme un pulse un
peu il y avait plein de pièces comme ça
et on n'avait pas vraiment l'impression
de comprendre ce que c'était et quelques
pièces en plus moi d'un coup les choses
commencent à tomber en place et c'est
vrai que mon futur je le veux je
commence à le voir déjà et je le veux
toujours en état créatif c'est à dire si
je suis pas créatif je suis je vais pas
très bien donc il faut que je il faut
que je fasse les choses d'amour étonnant
que lui à force de la croiser sur des
plateaux skis sur vous ça commence à la
hisser par henri la président du conseil
général des loups et je reçois noire la
truffe à la truffe j'adore pour moi mais
tu chies bien alors vous avez dit je
suis complètement névrosé mais je deale
avec quoi un peu comme nous tous
finalement oui je suis je suis aller
bronzer bref j'ai l'habitude ça fait des
années maintenant voilà ouais si je
n'étais plus peut-être que ce serait
très déconcertant pour moi donc c'est un
peu comme henry qui lui est libre comme
max en là on l'a vu tout à l'heure c'est
vrai libre une manche à rien ça peut
jésus
appelez le chat jésus honnêtement c'est
pas sympa pour jésus non 7h franchement
cet accueil qu de films américains
d'accor larmes aux yeux pour nous
catholiques c'est mon fils qui est
déclenché à karl marx ça vous fait de la
peine
pas du tout alors vous êtes libres ou dj
pas d'âge pas d'enfant rien vous dites
je peux tout faire je peux chanter ce
que jouer j'ai envie de réaliser je peux
écrire je suis sans étiquette quoi enfin
j'ai envie de tout faire je sais pas
peut-être je vais pas forcément tout
faire bien mais c'est vrai que vous êtes
un peu comme mathilde seigner mais dans
un an dans un autre genre que vous avez
un avis sur tout c'est à dire que par
exemple le toit je lisais dans
libération vous disiez toutes les
religions sont connes
ceci étant on peut le dire j'ai dit on
peut dire quand j'ai un problème avec la
religion
surtout en ce moment et surtout en
vivant aux etats unis
ouais j'ai un gros problème j'en avais
pas avant c'est à dire éduqué en france
par deux régions était 7 h à l'église et
de l'état ici aux etats-unis il ya un
problème aux etats unis c'est vrai que
ça m'a la constitution européenne la
laïcité
ah ben oui ah oui vous et moi ah oui
c'est vrai oui je vais rester là à
laurent ridel est resté là et dès qu'on
va aborder un sujet vous allez me dire
tu sais menacés ou ou pas par le oui
allait ou non au référendum le 29 mai
voilà vous n'êtes pas très nana je vous
comparez à mathilde seigner en fait vite
les histoires de nana ça me fait chier
serre que le film tout pour plaire à
quelqu'un qui est vachement bien failli
tout votre truc c'est que j'aime pas
passer des heures à parler de tout de
nanars on va dire j'aime pas chocques si
j'aime pas j'aime pas trop quoi j'aime
mieux parler d'autre chose de de cinéma
l'art de jouir ça j'aime pas trop parler
de mecs pendant des heures je me fais
vite chier avec ces sujets là je
comprends pas de ballet pas avoir tout
pour plaire alors écoutez remplit plus
que oui ça va pas vous plaire je ne sais
pas je sais des nanas c'est un peu comme
le coeur des hommes c'est le coeur des
femmes c'est des nanas qui risquait de
mettre à côté je sais pas vous n'avez
pas vu vous le verrez pas sûrement je
vais voir deux trois films à paris déjà
il y en a beaucoup qui sont sortis en
voir quelques-uns qui sont sortis comme
ça et à paris vous habitez où j'habite
dans le 15ème au dessus de chez mes
parents à l'attack ok bon vous êtes
contre la chirurgie esthétique aussi un
j'avais dit le look canard je suis pas
femme
déjà que j'ai du mal à me raser les
jambes génial c'est le très nature oui
j'ai pas envie de me faire
non mais écoutez ça c'est personnel
c'est un choix personnel je crée qui
parce que les autres font et moi j'ai
pensé je vous avais d'élèves normal vous
je ne vous avais pas le pas du tout
danger rien j'ai mieux je m'épile pas
facile ça ne faut pas le dire oui
d'accord
pas de souci je me fais pas grand chose
disons voyez je fais rien je change pas
grand chose à mon physique
le maillot qui est un tout petit peu de
sport quand j'ai le temps le maillot pas
vraiment non plus vraiment fait sous les
draps quand même il se rase pas m'étonne
qu'elle paye le losc car oui c'est moi
c'est nous
dans l'ain n'est pas très nanar elle
efface ronald julie c'est vrai j'ai un
petit ami qui remarque absolument pas
ces choses-là arrivent à venir petite
amie justement les mais qui n'intéresse
pas beaucoup plus à retrouver
l'équilibré dit avec les allemands les
nordiques parce qu'ils ont eu une
éducation féministe alors hein mais
kanak est calme quoi la mecque et pas
macho qui à vos ordres
un mec qui loupe c'est fini non il peut
le voir de temps en temps mais c'est
vrai que j'aime bien les hommes qui me
respecte
c'est vrai que j'aime je suis neuf une
femelle dominante je mens oui mais je
dis pas que je suis une femme qui
maltraitent les hommes où qu'ils soient
dominante au point où la laisser à une
relation de soin au moins égalitaire au
temps libre et égalitaire 20 exactement
et c'est vrai que tout le temps tout le
temps moi j'aimais très remuant quinze
jours j'ai dit ah c'est pas juste parce
que quand on est avec les autres c'est
normal mais après quand on est tous les
deux non non j'aimerais toujours qualité
bien j'ai une question pourquoi vous me
demandez ça va pour savoir si on
pourrait s'entendre tous les deux manon
alors façon vous êtes en main vous avez
un ingé son allmend musique il n'y a pas
de traduction française de sachets passé
il supervise la musique tu es et voilà
il a 30 ans et alors c'est quoi la chute
peut y a pas de suivi les bonbons à la
chute
c'est par vous n'êtes pas avec ethan
hawke n'était pas avec kiffan tendance
est un grand ami un grand homme et on
est dans travailler ensemble et c'est
pour ça qu'on a fait ce film mais hitano
qu'il n'est plus avec uma thurman non
plus non je crois que ça sert ouais
ouais mais vous dites en parlant nous ne
serons pas le goût du temps vous vous
dites elle doit pas avoir beaucoup de
copines
non c'est pas quelqu'un de très
chaleureux mais je veux dire c'est pas
mon problème un jeu moins j'en ai rien à
faire l'été c'est paradoxal quand même à
ckoi paradoxal une fille paradoxal c'est
plein de paradoxes d'accord si vous
voulez faire une interview paradoxe
julie un défaut que vous aimeriez avoir
être plus peut-être manipulatrice une
qualité que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir
docile docile merci docile
merci une mauvaise critique qui vous
ferait plaisir que je suis trop têtu un
compliment que vous n'aimeriez pas
recevoir
j'aimerais pas qu'on dise que je suis
mignonnette way un malheur qui vous
donneraient la pêche tombée enceinte par
accident
une attention que vous ne supportez pas
une attention que je supporte pas je ne
supporte pas trop l'attention en général
j'aime être tranquille il n'a insultes
que vous aimez entendre et
raddas et pétards et kaunas le plus beau
but que vous êtes pris dans votre vie
julie écoutez c'est très récent j'ai
reçu un prix de meilleure actrice à
londres du public
gg j'étais sur scène devant tout le
monde et j'ai commencé à raconter une
blague et j'ai oublié la punchline à
lachute là jusque voilà le plus bourrin
cocon est racontée sur vous qu'elle
allait voter oui non que j'étais c'est
pas un ragot on a raconté que j'étais
chiante par exemple le geste tendre qui
vous énerve
ah oui quand maman quand j'étais petit
me faisais pour nettoyer la figure à des
tests le cadeau que vous détestez
des chocolats la phrase que vous
détestez dire je suis désolé ouais non
c'est pas vrai non j'aime pas dire s'il
vous plaît la manière des mots la
manière de mourir qui vous fera plaisir
comme jeanne calment tenus envers doses
voilà
[Musique]
mais bin hammam 5 un nouveau truc dans
ses missions mais
ah oui d'accord aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe henri carte michel drucker vous
devez remercier ce sens qui vous quoi
sans qui vous ne seriez pas là j'ai
problème quand y'a des trucs mes parents
godard tavernier
qui d'autre qu'est-ce-qui
richard llung latorre it and rock mais
moi je compte pour du beurre moi je vois
tu paies un film sur soi et tout en
mairie 3 ben oui mais toi mais je
t'oublie tout le temps bien sûr
voilà
d'excellentes chansons
oh
le
[Musique]
j'accueille antonio d'amico
retenu la nique aux jurys des filles en
rythme annuel ils ont rebâti alors le 15
juillet 1997 à 8h45 en plein ocean drive
à miami le couturier gianni versace été
assassiné de deux balles calibre 40
ce jour là il était allé chercher le
journal tout seul vous viviez avec lui
depuis 15 ans pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
les acheter le journal avec lui ce matin
là alors je ne sais pas vraiment pas ce
qu'il était et se réveiller très tôt il
est parti pour acheter les journaux et
moi je me suis réveillé à cette année
plus ou moins et puis j'attendais un ami
pour l'aller 1-1 jouer au tennis
alors là ça ça andrew keen annan sera
retrouvé suicidé la tête explosée par
une balle du même calibre
le 23 juillet suivant dans un house boat
de indian creek
on est sûr que c'était lui l'assassin
qu'est ce que je peux dire à certains
moi je veux un garçon 1
juste après l'attitude accords soir et
les garçons que j'ai vu c'était lui
après quand je suis rentré en italie la
personne qu'ils ont trouvé dans la baie
de la house boat vous avez identifié
ça ça vous a pas demandé de revenir en
amérique vous vérifier si oui alors là
ça sans aucune annan était un prostitué
gay de 27 ans on a dit que gianni
versace et vous le connaissiez pas du
tout je n'avais pas de la connaissance
de celui là jusqu'à le jour que je vous
le dis que c'était lui ouais j'aime
levier jamais vu avant moi jamais on a
dit qu'il était amoureux de vous vous
aviez une affaire sais pas je ne sais
pas d'accord ce coup de non finalement
l' enquête a été close sans explication
du meurtre vous savez je crois que il ya
des personnes qui devient peu
mythomane appartements notamment parce
que il avait déjà tué quatre personnes
et il a tué johnny et pied ils avaient
ils ont dit qu'ils avaient encore de
tuer trois personnes à los angeles
alors vous vous dites de toute façon qui
n'est pas vraiment d'affaires parce que
gianni et vous aviez une vie
irréprochable
vous dites que et trinquer tranquille
ouais pas d'alcool non pas du tout pas
de cocaïne jamais vous dites que c'est
plutôt la soeur de gianni cependant
qu'il a dit elle a dit acquis à tout le
monde
ouais le sortir parce qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital à new york
et quand il a dû dire que il prenait de
la coke mille dollars par jour oui six
chefs d'accusation beaucoup d'argent
alors vous aviez rencontré gianni
versace d'une quinzaine d'années à
l'époque il avait fait les costumes pour
un gala à la scala oui et quand il vous
a vu au dîner qui a succédé à cette
représentation
il est tombé fou d'amour pour vous
conseiller espèce de ses seins c'est ça
qui m'a dit tu sais il a eu un coup de
foudre pour vous je ne sais pas
je crois qu'il avait
trouver quelqu'un qui il était l'image
de la bouteille classique un temps je
sais pas mais moi c'était trop jeune
vous aviez 24 ans lui 37
voilà et voilà ensuite c'était une
espèce de conte de fées une une vraie
romance gay et un josé même déclaré vous
avez annoncé votre amour ce serait le
premier couturier
dans les monts qui a fait la déclaration
a bien joué mais j'étais homosexuel qui
l'a fait non comme quoi du tout vous
avez fait ensemble un article dans un
magazine gay us qui savaient dès
advocate cet article dandy advocate
c'était un petit peu là la consécration
médiatique de votre de votre union
mais la famille versace n'acceptez pas
du tout que vous viviez ensemble et
c'est un peu bizarre parce que c'est la
famille vers sortie n'acceptez pas agi
pas compris parce que et s'est mariée
avec le garçon qui était avant les
années avant moi c'était un fils et deux
jeunes dont un peu bizarre l'histoire
mais en tous les cas d'aidé la mort de
gianni versace vous avez été vous avez
été chassés quoi tel aborde lui avec ma
famille et moi je pu contacter ça a
commencé le matin du meurtre puisque
vous êtes interdit de l'ambulance on
vous interdit d'accompagner le corps de
gianni versace à l'hôpital et on vous
emmène dans un commissariat pour pour
témoigner et vous avez passé toute la
journée à rennes jusqu'à 10 heures le
soir sans pitié comme ça parce que je
n'ai jamais d'aller jouer au tennis au
froid avec l'air conditionné qu'elle
fait à 1000 pas d'avoir rien de tout
nous dit si ç'avait été une femme une
femme mariée avec gianni versace
on l'aurait pas emmener au poste on
l'aurait d'abord laissé l hôpital quoi
sur ouais je crois que cela apporte tout
consommer c'est vrai alors pas le droit
d'aller vers l'hôpital pas le droit de
l'habiller pas le droit de choisir
l'endroit où ses cendres seront seront
enterrés et tout ça malgré une vie de 15
ans ensemble tout simplement 24 heures
sur 24
parce que c'était difficile parce que
après quinze ans tu penses que tu as des
droits oui avec la personne que tu as
aimé pour l'entente mais là dans un
minus et quand c'est le tout c'est tout
je t'aime vous avez été écarté de
l'héritage
c'est vrai qu'à un moment gianni versace
vous avez proposé 20% des actions de sa
société où les aviez refusé
et là vous avez été complètement rayé de
l'héritage de versace exactement vivait
obtenu quoi une rente jusqu'en 2007
c'est ça une rente de 25000 euros par
mois jusqu'en 2007 lui il faut lever les
taxes qui sont tous deux la moitié
vous avez aussi la jouissance des des
maisons de gianni versace mais vous avez
déclaré que pour vous c'était difficile
d'aller dans des maisons où il n'était
plus là finalement c'était oui
d'abord c'était très difficile parce que
avec tous les objets tous les choses car
on a acheté ensemble la vie inconnue ça
fait ça fait du mal à les voir et puis
après parce que il n'y avait vraiment
pas l'exigence de rester là bas avec la
famille qui mcafee j'ai complètement
dont un mois je dis vous partir si ce à
dire que vous avez travaillé encore
quelques mois chez versace ou épuisés la
femme dans la rue voilà vous êtes parti
avec vos indemnités
en janvier j'ai terminé la collection
que je vais commencer je suis morte et
vous dites la façon dont il traitait les
robes mini team été les robes par terre
il n'y avait pas de respect comme du
temps de bernard
non parce que johnny il a il avait eu un
respect pour le travail des personnes
qui travaillaient pour lui et dans les
robes même les robes et les touchez pas
tellement lui mais il voulait pas qu'ils
les touchent et les autres il y avait
des personnes qui le prenaient leur
portée et gens m'aident à part faire
parce que c'était moi y est donc
alors johnny fait de ses nièces
allègre à la l'héritière principal de sa
fortune à 2 50% des parts il ya des
passes capable aujourd'hui de gérer la
faire parce que l'anorexie qu'elle est
malade
exactement elle est tombée malade juste
deux mois après un seul à vraiment se
faire mal à la petite
cet après midi il était très proche de
ses nièces il a appelé ma princesse
était très proche d'elle et
malheureusement aujourd'hui elle est pas
en mesure de lui succéder donc c'est sa
soeur donne at elle acquis qui s'occupe
des affaires de versace mettre en ménage
s'il y avait le pacs en italie commis en
france
les choses auraient été différentes
pauvres oui oui ça reste quand même ça
n'existe pas en italie
si vous avez des politiciens en italie
qui sont quand même but idiot mais vous
avez beauty l'yonne celui que ses
bouteilles auraient déclaré que
l'homosexualité est un péché
vous avez fini qui vient du parti ex
fasciste disant lieu jacques te ment il
a déclaré que
e
l'homosexuel peut pas rentrer dans
l'école pour un seigneur dans l'école
parce que c'est le problème c'est avec
l'argent qu'on semble vraiment été que
ça voilà un pays où il n'ya pas le pacs
ou la voilà le résultat
et puis est un pays où la lys à fait sûr
de l'église et le fort
voilà c'est tout parce que ça comprend
pas est ce qu'il y ait des pride en
italie il faut dégraisser et ridicule
parce que tous les x il faut voir hier
soir les mecs qui vont avec les pumas
lettre qu'a pu mais si jamais tout cela
se serait passé à l'anomie ses qualités
sur un nom aujourd'hui ça va mieux donc
ça y est vous commencez à vous reprendre
à je retrouvais ma la sérénité devant un
mot c'est à vivre après plus tant qu'ils
y penser quand même souvent adjani dans
la journée ça vous obsède où il est il
est présent tout l'avis de tous les
temps quand il est là avec moi
j'ai des moments qui sont un peu tristes
des moments qui
je pense la vie qu'on a passé ensemble
mais ça va mieux s'il n'avait pas été
assassiné vous seriez rester encore
longtemps
enfin c'est jouer c'est donc dans l'émoi
des marsois devient 22 ans
non ça fait longtemps
[Musique]
richard bohringer
le charbon bessalah
je vis tout de suite j'ai beaucoup aimé
ton lire ton livre est beau mais son
livre est beau et je le conseille voilà
or le livre de richard s'appelle
l'ultime conviction du désir c'est
publié chez flammarion 150 pages est une
espèce de carnets de voyage des
instantanés poétique en afrique dans
l'océan indien cuba même en islande à un
moment alors c'est un texte en forme de
déclaration d'amour au monde à ta femme
aux enfants à l'humanité c'est très
poétique et presque parfois incantatoire
c'est très habités comme comme comme
texte alors bien sûr on va commencer
avec l'afrique parce que c'est quelque
chose de deux centrales
tu parles du rallye paris dakar avec les
enfants qui courra après les stylos
qu'on leur balance et tu parles du rire
des collabos qui font semblant de croire
que c'est vachement généreux tous ses
stylos quand la relance aux mômes oui je
suis fondamentalement comme ça je suis
contre le paris dakar oui c'est vrai
quitte à me faire d ici je m'en fous je
veux dire que si on parle de la mort de
l'afrique et de l'amour du désert je
vois pas comment à 200 kilomètres à
l'heure on peut apprécier cet amour là
ouais j'avais un ami qui était un grand
chef touareg qui se plaît mano dayak
c'est connu il avait fait le premier
parcours du paris dakar en pensant que
tous les pays traversés ça donnerait au
village ainsi de suite il a arrêté un
deuxième année la pure fait donc cet
homme qui était un homme du désert
on peut pas dire great war etc soit
particulièrement tendre et tout un
il a quand même vu que son peuple était
complètement bafouée dans cette histoire
là entre le mali ont fait ainsi que
j'étais tout cas c'est donc sur accor et
le paris dakar de super fan non point je
n'en dirai pas plus parce que je pense
qu'effectivement un contrat ce
extraordinaire d'abord entre ces
occidentaux qui viennent s'amuser ou en
tout cas
relevé un défi qui leur appartient puis
ces populations qui sont très souvent
très dépourvu ce serait pour pour passer
le paris-dakar en europe à condition que
votre nom l'abbé les fameux stylo c'est
vrai que les mecs qui regardent même pas
où ils tombent les uns il est juste
comme ça pour trouble sur les marchés
mais j'ai des cahiers d'abord c'est des
nommés mais il est bon mais il sauf ali
donc les revendre des stylos donkey les
aventures on les retrouve sur tous les
marchés quoi de large et et des stylos
ils feraient mieux de leur construire
des puits des choses comme ça par
exemple jamais jamais d'eau
des pastis le 23 alors tu parles de
saint louis du sénégal il ya une fois ce
que c'est très bien écrit en fait c'est
terrible de parler de ça comme ça parce
qu'il faut le lire quoi le bouquin il ya
une phrase formidable c'était à saint
louis du sénégal le soir la voix du muet
jean qui tricotent le rap mystique c'est
bien il ya des phrases comme ça il ya
banlieue de bongo alors là c'est il ya
un côté quand même chaudron de
l'humanité quoi il ya un qu'audrey
walpurgis c'est à dire que yahia ton ami
sculpteur là le belge qui fait ses
sculptures et puis son chien qui
s'attaque aux warrants pour les
bestioles je me demandais pourquoi mes
compagnons sénégalais voulait jamais à
bongo il va jamais y aller dit
l'analyste tomber bongo laisse tomber
bain et se tombait bongo puis un jour je
recrute un belge d'une trentaine
d'années énormément de talent et emilie
bas vient dans mon atelier je suis dit
où est ton atelier m'bia bongo dans la
forêt est effectivement son atelier de
bambou dans la forêt les doigts une
forêt à c'est assez dur quoi ça veut
dire tous les reptiles de la création ça
veut dire débat rando qui sont les
bestioles de cauchemar
messier du diable on voit pas le corps
quand elles sont dans l'eau et on ne
sait pas très bien où sont les yeux par
rapport à la bouche quoi sert il
s'asseoir et ça passe comme ça quoi
c'est dégueulasse il invité qui
ressemblait à ça et puis voilà piano il
ya des choses aussi une fusion de
rentrer c'est l'afrique quoi entre les
hommes les animaux la terre le ciel
il ya un moment tu raconte l'histoire
sur une piste d'un buffle qui s'enlise
et c'était au mali pendant la panda
l'hivernage ça veut dire la saison des
pluies j'étais avec mon fils sur la
piste et est brusquement on ne
s'enlisent nous aussi on dérive même
d'abord on voit d'abord la tête d'un
buffle énorme et nappez posé il ya plus
de corps il est dans les sables et le
regard c'est vrai je n'invente pas un
regard de d'humains preuve ouais je le
savais c'est fini fatigué j'en peux plus
terminé et puis les trois maliens qui
était en train d'en sortir d'essayer
d'en sortir un qui lui même aspirer don
kelly
disparaît dans la boue donc je suis là
ils veulent le sortir un élu par et lui
parle il s'arc boutent mais il est déjà
il est déjà jusqu'à là il a carrément la
tête posée sur la tête c'est vous il ya
plus de corps ya plus rien et c'était à
la fois éblouissant de d'humanité de
proximité comme ça ouais ils l'ont sauvé
et si c'était c'était une bagarre
affolant dans la peine d'amour fusionnel
circonstances dans le regard de du boeuf
quoi tu sens quelque chose de à wen
s'était c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment magnifique que c'était la
tragédie animal à qui on qui rejoignait
la tragédie humaine en fait l'intérêt
c'était magnifique c'était magnifique à
l'instantané comme ça qu au mieux des
milliers en afrique sur lequel il vaut
mieux de temps en temps ça aurait été
trop longtemps parce que si on a rien à
faire c'est trop dur alors là tu parles
de l'afrique super de l'océan indien la
réunion il ya un concert dans la dans la
montagne un 2000 m d'altitude chez des
indiens fut une journée pour monter
c'est quelque chose à gens il
faut plus qu'une journée et il faut des
bonnes cannes il faut pas avoir le
vertige mais je sais qu'au lait s'est
collé sur les flancs de la montagne et
les sentiers de temps en temps ils sont
vraiment large pour la largeur depuis
que c'est vraiment une île très très
sportive
les gars qui aiment la marche qui aiment
la montagne quand même la vraie nature
du rpt la réunion c'est magnifique mais
je vous l'avais amené un grand leader
jusqu'à quand dont je parle dans ce
qu'on a vu ici oui mais voilà vous me
l'aviez invités c'était sympa hein tu
parles des fleurs des fruits des odeurs
des légumes et potirons comme les
ballons ça quand on arrive en haut on
est très récompensé en fait ouais ouais
mais nous on avait tellement but de
rendre la veille qu'on s'est fait la
dépose dans l'hélico est comme il est
on a besoin les héros mais après on a
monté la battre hommes à monter tout le
truc dans le village goal qui était
accroché à mafate comme ça il y avait il
ya quoi là où elles sont venues à 8,15
quoi mais brusquement au fur et à mesure
que ce ce magnifique leader cet homme
charismatique pounia le leader de jyske
à caen a commencé à s'était il ay là il
a donné un concert à 2000 mètres
d'altitude la batterie les pieds de la
batterie dans la terre battue et ainsi
de suite avec un avec un fil électrique
des ampoules qui pendent régime et d'un
seul coup je me suis retournée et toute
la montagne étaient venus au concert
toute la montagne parce que le son
résonné dans toute la montagne donc tous
les villages qui étaient encore plus ou
encore plus perdus il arrivait il venait
il y avait des touristes qui dormait au
fusil a même acheté il ya c'était
magnifique
ça c'est la réunion à l'île maurice a
beaucoup moins de sympathie pour l'île
maurice un tu parles de kaka dans la
soir tu dis à ceux qui nettoient et ce
qui ne doit même pas bah ouais parce que
dès qu'on sort moi j'étais invité déjà
dansé dansé endroit luxueux magnifique
c'est extraordinaire c'est vrai c'est
super on al impression qu on a
l'impression d'être le roi du pétrole
mais à l'intérieur de maurice les
mauriciens c'est quand même plus
intéressant quoi tu parles de cuba tu
dis tout le monde sait que le barbu est
un tyran les prisons sont pleines le
peuple se tait c'est à dire qu'en fait
le monde attend qu'il crève quoi bas et
c'est pas non plus peut-être une
solution pour les cubains quoi je sais
très ambigu lors ceux qui sont restés
c'est d'abord c'est un peuple magnifique
un ouais ah ouais c'est un peu ma vie
alors évidemment le la fin de la phase
la plus souriante des cubains c'est que
f
effectivement ils savent tous lit à tous
écrire ils connaissent tous une histoire
de leur pays
il ya l'ue survient il perd brillant il
ya des sportifs des grands sportifs
il ya vraiment un peuple extravagant il
très très brillant y a rien sur les
étagères ouais
et puis il ya quand même les cas les
comités de révolutionnaire de chaque
crue c'est à dire il faut que tu
balances si tu balances pas été un
mauvais révolutionnaire mais on ne
balance pas ton pote ton frère ton père
te merde t'es là quand j'ai demandé sur
ses pieds pour ou là ou contre la chute
de castro vous saviez pas trop quoi j'ai
dit oui parce que
les mêmes raisons il ya à la fois des
choses mayer et cuba ont réussi mille
médecins ont venezuela bon et on et puis
en même temps il ya des choses horribles
quoi rire moi j'ai vu des enfants
mendier autour de la statue du che tu
dis heureusement qu'ils voient pas ce à
quoi et alors un vieux relents de
racisme est évident un jeune guerrier
padilla pas y'a pas de vrais cubain dans
le gouvernement
ouais hein c'est les blancs d'oeufs les
espagnols et dans les hôtels à cuba à
part danser sur la piste pour les
touristes dans le spectacle de je ne
sais quoi
ailleurs dans les autres hôtels et les
blacks aussi l'on parle de rentrée ouais
donc j'ai dit une image très dur tu pars
à kohat est une cité made in rda c'est à
dire république démocratique allemande
c'est un immeuble qui a été construit
par les allemands de l'est ouais et qui
est en ruine au milieu de la chaussée
alors ça veut dire que c'est presque
c'est apocalypse now quoi il ya des gens
qui vivent là dedans c'est noir fumé il
ya les lianes il ya la jungle qui a pris
son pouvoir là-dessus alors qu'il
instaure cette image comme ça dans ton
bouquin très est vraiment des moments
alors l'islande aussi en place un autre
moment qui était un dimanche après-midi
et la piscine municipale de ridge à bic
en islande
ouais c'est là où on joue comme des
homards eh ouais ça va il ya trois cuves
de alors qu'il toutes les familles se
foutent de dents et les enfants le père
la mère le grand père il ya trois cuves
d'une une température différente quoi il
ya la grosse à 40° tu sortais rouge
il ya bien la glace et au bout s'il faut
faire un jeu trouble dans l'année alors
il ya aussi des philippines dans ton
bouquin manille
on y vient des marchands cam déguisé en
fleuristes des marchands de petite fille
le chapelet à la main des bons 10,6 en
syrie ce qui est très étonnant dans les
philippines c'est un film d'abel ferrara
quoi exactement la constitution les
crucifix
les malices energy manager armand us le
basket c'était le mec qui venait me
chercher j'ai été capitaine d'un cargo
le sofa la main il avait qui venait me
chercher pour l'emmener en ville la
première le premier qui vient me
chercher je monte dans laquelle je monte
à côté de lui et il ya sur le sur le
montant comme ça il ya la croix il ya la
vierge elle s'appelait être une hache
ainsi du temps mais qui fait fort comme
et puis à un moment il mais il croit que
je comprends pas et je donc je continue
le truc ils me disent tu veux une petite
fille ouais puis au bout d'un moment
comme on en a juste dit quand je
comprends pas très bien là le tout ça là
c'est du pipeau alors c'est ça c'est ta
fille que tu me proposes si ces
cinéastes sais quoi mais je venais
difficile
et puis il va tous les mecs dans les
villes avec les des fusils à canon scié
qui sont des espèces de milice de
surveillance parce qu'il ya des attentes
à tous les jours des enlèvements tous
les jours en manie donc le quartier le
quartier kalachnikov et vigueur
copé 1 il est entouré de barbelés à 6tu
la medellin ta description oui c'est un
peu ça à manille ouais c'est dur à il
manie du rail vraiment vraiment avec les
processions religieuses ensanglanté
comme ça des pleurs des cris des hommes
qui se flagellent un homme importe la
croix pendant des kilomètres 5 de parts
et c'est très très fort assez dense
alors tu dis ma vie mais plus rien à
voir avec la vie d'un acteur parisien
c'est sûr oui c'est fini c'est fini la
whey ce qui ressort de ce bouquin c'est
une espèce de pessimisme flamboyant
comme ça c'était ensuite un pessimisme
qui en fait bon c'était pas vraiment à
vivre l'écriture ça sautait d'un peu
quoi mais où il ya quand même un
désespoir comme ça une conscience de des
malheurs de l'humanité qui s'éteint je
suis devenu une grosse éponge moins
grosses dépenses mais mais écrire ouais
moi ça me sert pas de ccc des béquilles
jusqu'au mot fin quoi ouais mais après
ça commence quoi ça sert à rien de me
vient de loin les couvertures de
magazines et puis l'oubli une veste trop
grande que j'ai laissé glisser sans me
retourner
c'était mieux là maintenant tu préfères
ça va moins sérieux
ouais ouais ce qui est bien c'est ce que
tu dis de ta femme tu dis c'est mon âme
art profonde
bah oui c'est assez bien ce terme amar
profonde
voilà en tous les cas c'est un très beau
livre s'appelle l'ultime conviction du
désir richard bohringer chez flammarion
bravo
alors c'est un livre qui est écrit dans
l'urgence un petit peu comme une
bouteille à la mer contre la contre la
désespérance
on va être encore plus dans l'urgence
richard on va faire une interview
adios echard si vous mourriez demain si
vous deviez mourir demain qu'est ce que
vous voudriez faire absolument ce soir
avec mes enfants
ouais ouais tu préviendrait qui
appartint femmes et des enfants de ta
mort demain matin non mais c'est un jeu
riche
je ne me sens pas très bien alors le
matin oui je vais très bien qui je
pourrai prévenir moi je sais pas moi je
sais pas parce que ce que je voudrais
pas dire ils sont plus là dans les bras
de qui tu aimerais passer cette dernière
nuit à dans les bras de ma famille
beaumont et koné est-ce que tu
essayerait toi même d'écrire là la nécro
ou la dépêche d'ems sont à mort ouais
ouais pourquoi pas un vrai t'es
coûterait quelle musique
jimmy ouais tu penserais quoi demain
comme fringues pour ta mort un truc qui
m'irait bien
ouais ça peut bien gardé longtemps
commence
et si tu devais voter pour l'europe
avant de décider
oui et non ben j'ai appris que le oui
c'est l ouverture au libéralisme total
sur toute l'europe
j'ai appris ça parce que c'est pas très
clair dans le 10 ans ils ont trouvé
beaucoup c'est vrai non non vraiment les
bonnes raisons les mauvaises raisons et
et que le nom freinerait cet excès de
libéralisme mais je le problème si je
pense qu'on est déjà très très loin de
libéralisme alors le pire est à venir
croyez moi c'est la soirée des bons
richard tu meurs demain là ouais tu
aimerais tu fasses qu'elle tend à suis
là aujourd'hui
ouais ouais tu seras triste de mourir
soulagés peut-être au nom non j'aime
vachement la vie est curieux c'est parce
que après qu'eurent une tête qui aurait
peut-être que your way est ce que tu
préfères sa saveur cela mourir demain
matin ou une mort violente inattendue un
accident inattendu
ouais tu paieras tes factures on ne peut
partir
elles sont payées et après demain une
fois que tu seras au paradis tu rêves de
retrouver qui abat j'ai un paquet là où
vous êtes allé boire un coup et roland
blanchet mes trucs qu'on a mais en
arrivant ils sont là où il ya philippe
léotard et roland ils m'attendent
l'instant sans glaçon dire un roland
j'aimerais qu'il dise quoi demain soir
poivre d'arvor au journal pour annoncer
sa mort il est fou mais quelle phrase tu
veux qu'ils disent un acteur célèbre des
années 80 ouais est décédé alors on ne
le voyait plus beaucoup à l'écran il se
faisait rare il va le faire encore plus
voilà par exemple très bien
ah ouais bah tu devrais faire les textes
de poivre d'arvor ça serait plus drôle
en rien et croit surtout je rejoins
il m'a invité dans son émission il avait
lu le bouquin j'ai dis moi tu
accepterais de donner quelques organes à
nation soit les x men la série et je
vous les yeux de tes yeux
je pourrais donner tes yeux les noms
parce que bien avant si dans un bocal
c'était gens qui voudraient qu'il fasse
la nécro alors au cimetière là qui qui
va venir faire le discours dix mois
passés comme ça on le saura
pierre bénichou pierre bénichou à battre
est bien ouais a très bien a pas
d'accord avec ce une bonne idée
ah ouais pas pierre bénichou bas il va
commencer à ce qu'il sait pas beaucoup
plus
comme l'écrit barre des 6 mètres
maintenant pierre blazy toi tu meurs
avant toi tu meurs avant moi je veux
bien lui faire la sienne est ce que tu
penses que tu auras une belle vis tu
meurs demain matin ah ouais ouais ouais
un bon temps ah bah je ne pouvais pas en
espérer autant ouais ouais c'est bien
alors bon ba un a dios salut
sur mêlée
je viens marion j'ai beau charmant âgées
t
les lignes arrière de votre démission
des pc à aa
vous devez vous giflé et tient une autre
cas ça s'est passé très chargée le faire
les attends toi à mestalla tu crois
gouache devisent gaiement bras où
l'image est tellement sale
voilà qu'est ce que c'est toi je ne sais
quoi vous devez embrassé sur la bouche
l'invité de votre choix
non je ne vais pas dû car j'ai pas vous
je veux pas lui faire vivre un calvaire
subi ce cadre je suis pas la seule
invitée regardes tu vois bien tranquille
la bise mais mon copain quoi un copain
et charbon chez lui
mission du désir c'est publié chez
flammarion melanson
j'accueille sylvie testud
ça va mais têtue vous connaissez tous le
monde à peu près au je crois bohringer
delpy emmanueli antonio d'amico qui
était le compagnon de gianni versace
voilà alors vous avez déclaré le cinéma
est pour moi une manière d'éviter de
prendre des décisions quant au metteur
en scène me dit aujourd'hui tu dois être
de mauvaise humeur
ça m'arrange ouais c'est vrai donc ce
soir je vous dis soit de bonne humeur
voilà ça m'arrange ça marche c'est vrai
vous êtes comme ça c'est génial
ouais je trouve que c'est c'est agréable
en fait il ya quelque chose en moins a
décidé le matin je sais pas il ya
quelque chose qui me rassure quand
quelqu'un commandes un peu moins
quelqu'un prend les décisions à ma place
ça me libère sa m'allège alors au cinéma
vous avez déjà été lauréate de deux
césar avec les blessures assassines
meilleur espoir
stupeur et tremblements meilleure
actrice c'est vrai que votre grand mère
vous a demandé si le césar était
vraiment en or oui c'est vrai alors tout
va très bien pour vous parce qu'il ya
les deux césars en plus y'a votre livre
de nouvelles il n'y a pas beaucoup des
toiles ce soir qui a été salué par la
critique
un nouveau livre à paraître cette année
en avril qui s'appelle le ciel t'aidera
voilà donc ça va pour vous nous savons
tous ce que vous faites marche on verra
il efface orties ouais mais faire un
disque bientôt non avant pourquoi
non il ya une chose que je fais pas bien
c'est vraiment chanter avant que toutes
les actrices sondés disent les
enquêteurs
non là vraiment c'est la catastrophe les
autres voulaient dire non non non moi
c'est vraiment la création vrille et
enfin ça marchera non moi j'ai atteint
les sommets la moelle et puis en plus
j'aime pas ça donc voilà qu'est ce qu'il
y a les deux faits la page
bouillon de poule dans l'épaule ce put
est la plus élevée c'est pas vrai quoi
moi je mets bien côté de soi avec des
liasses way we est inquiète pour les
jeux vient côté de top si j'ai besoin
c'est comme ça tout d'abord si j'ai
besoin d'apprendre à pourquoi tu mets
dans m je cherche de pognon en france et
en plus je te laisse faire fut un moment
j'ai voulu venir vous reverra des clés
ainsi que les images donnent envie de
voter pour lui il marque des points ce
soir
en tous les cas chez des chevaliers des
arts et lettres ça a dû être un gamin un
choc à la maison non ouais c'était au
départ ce n'est pas très identifiée par
le reste de la famille soeur qui m'ont
un peu demandé ce que c'était exactement
et puis voilà j'ai dû basse une médaille
qu'on remet au ministère de la culture
et alors là d'un coup ça a pris des
proportions monstrueuses tout le monde
était très content des chars aussi
quoique tu la toile la médaille des arts
et lettres
ouais un mail que j'ai brestois qui ne
l'est pas je t'ai dit toutes les
actrices ou les acteurs américains soit
qu'ils ont donné à sharon stone aussi
donnent tous les accès lors de juste
avant les élections c'est bien la voir
aussi mais c'est vrai vous dit ce fils
d'immigré j'avais besoin de quelque
chose d'officiel quoi je crois qu'en
fait il ya un moment on a envie que le
reste de la famille choix soient fiers
quoi voilà et il ya une histoire qui est
très jolie je sais pas si ça lui fera
plaisir je le raconte mais par exemple
ma grand mère un jour me fait de
l'acompte la confiture de prunes au no1
ccima me serrait pas comme ça donc là
elle me l'a écrit j'ai no1
ça me fait plaisir d'avoir dans ses yeux
ce petit regard où elle est contente
quoi pour ça que vous êtes entré au
conservatoire aussi oui je crois qu'il
ya un endroit où je m'étais dit j'ai
besoin de le faire pour après peut-être
être mécontente avec pour pouvoir dire
j'aime j'aime pas mais de le faire quoi
bien sûr qu'on le fait pas et qu'on dit
on l'a ou on aime pas c'est très bizarre
au moins ça me donnait le droit de le
valider de l'aimer ou de palet mais
points alors tout le monde se souvient
de stupeur et tremblements de cornaux
vous revenez avec un film de corneau qui
s'appelle les mots bleus avec sergi
lopez qui sort le 23 mars c'est fait le
pitch tient alors donc c'est l'histoire
d'une femme et de sa fille qui vivent en
fait très collées l'une à l'autre
cirque elles ont peur des mots il ya eu
petite douleur dans la fin une grosse
douleur dans la famille et la mère de
famille son sort mal sert qu'à cause des
maux il ya eu une mort il ya eu un drame
dans la famille et inconsciemment elle
reporte tout ce problème sur sa fille
qui du coup en dos le problème trop fort
elle ne parle plus et ce qui fait que
les deux ont besoin l'une de l'autre
pour vivre et la mère refuse un petit
peu le bonheur de perquis de peur qu'il
s'en aille
ouais et un jour des débats requin un
homme comme la petite fille ne parle pas
elle veut la mettre dans une école pour
sourds et muets alors qu'elle n'est pas
sourde et le professeur c'est sergi
lopez qui est un homme charmant qui lui
même a des problèmes et là il ya une
très belle histoire d'amour qui n'est
grâce à cette petite fille et un petit
peu voilà je viens faire moi on va voir
lequel elle mieux ouais bah non donc il
ya anaky je vais par camille gauthier
qui a 6 ans qui est élevé par sa mère
célibataire qui joué par vous vous vivez
toutes les deux en couple dans une
espèce de symbiose fusionnelle aucun
problème mais la gamine ne parle pas
elle n'est pas autiste elle est
simplement victime de mutisme voilà est
en fait la mère vous vous refusez de
lire et d'écrire parce que votre grand
mère est morte en vous lisant une
histoire voilà alors les deux ne
communique que par des dessins et la
gamine est envoyée effectivement dans
une école pour sourds muets ou le
pédagogue et sergi lopez voilà c'est un
métier non non alors lequel est le mieux
placé le vôtre on est vachement bien
dans ce camp mais on va garder les deux
montages il va choquer quand tu es en
bas on va laisser les gens choisir un
objet ce qu'on va faire je vais regarder
votre caméra et vous allez dire magnéto
serge vous connaissez le système oui
attention vous l'avez vu votre caméra
lancé loyal rôle je pense que c'est
celle qui est en face de moi voilà la
non réfléchi à tout tu peux alors
allons-y magnéto serge bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bonjour madame décidément anna ne
s'adaptent pas avez-vous pensé à la
mettre dans une école spécialisée
et elle n'est pas sourde
[Musique]
tu n'es pas chaude à la jamais parlé
elle a prévenu qu'elle apprenne à vivre
ils apprennent à se défendre
[Musique]
je très inquiète depuis qu'elle vient
ici à son fils tout en demandant quand
elle sera prête
[Musique]
les yeux
lâchez-moi leur apprendre à main vous
m'avez menti vous nous avez pas dit la
vérité
courmont menti on ne voulait pas qu'on
en apprenne à parler
non c'est ça
bon j'aurais peur de quoi
c'est prenable
voilà les meubles dans l'instant
avec sylvie testud et sergi lopez sorti
le 23 mars
alors je vais complètement transformé
alain corneau parce qu'avant il voulait
tourner qu'avec des mecs des polars et
maintenant ils adorent les gonzesses
quoi il fait que des films avec vous un
opus est un mot à lui c'est les
gonzesses je les ai surpris un jour en
train de dire à un journaliste
moi j'ai jamais fait de film avec des
gonzesses ouais au début j'ai dit bon
d'accord
non je sais pas si ça va devenir une
recette mais je crois qu'il était
content il est content bien lorsque bien
c'est que son sens du polar à éviter
qu'ils mettent trop de pathos dans ce
film qui aurait pu renaître plein quoi
c'est assez épuré quand même c'est ouais
puis en plus je crois que c'est un sujet
qui qu'il a pas beaucoup manipuler sert
les sentiments réellement amoureux une
vraie histoire d'amour et je crois
qu'ils avaient peur justement de tomber
un peu trop dans les grosses lignes et
et du coup ont été assez vigilant je
crois je vais faire un troisième film
avec lui j'en sais rien avant au nom
peut-être qu'il a envie de reprendre des
films avec des mecs maintenant alors
comment il va votre mec à vous ça va je
crois que ça va vrai 16 ans ces jeux-là
16 ans non c'est un petit peu dur à
croire mais à 16 ans qu'ils sont
ensemble 1 c'est vrai oui ta fidélité et
érotique vous y croyez vraiment à ça ben
jusqu'ici ça va je veux pas me dire ça
va être comme ça tout le temps parce que
bon j'en sais rien mais aussi saint jean
c'est bien également ça fait quand même
temps toi un éloge
ces regards des tâches est prise au jeu
disons le tout de suite un nom dont
certains non c'est ça oui c'est vrai et
comment il va le petit la rue ben il va
drôlement bien je vais bien
ouais quand même le père dévoué toujours
pas demande en mariage
quand même non c'est marrant ça pour
quoi mais je sais bien parce que je
crois qu'il a pour vie de m'épouser je
crois à c'était pourquoi
non je crois qu'il veut pas ça fait 16
ans que je n'ai que je lui demande t il
veut pas il veut pas non en même temps
si vous restez avec lui il s'en fout
voilà ouais alors vous êtes une jeune
maman donc voilà depuis un mois on va
faire des interviews jeune maman alors
pendant que d'appeler ruben à cause de
rubens barrichello vous aimez la formule
1 c'est ça non peut-être plus
ruben blanes mais non parce que je
trouve que le prénom est très beau puis
auch ou pas il a sauvé joseph dupuis
tout ça est ce que c'est le plus beau
bébé du monde ruben malgré sa tête de
têtards un peu un peu frites non non pas
du tout fripé c'est une merveille pas du
tout frites et c'est vrai qu'on descend
il ressemble à votre césar non non non
non il n'était pas non plus compressés
bon voilà et vous avez fait des photos
numériques que vous avez envoyé à toute
la famille voilà c'est bien vous êtes
une vraie et vous vous avez décidé à
l'été parce que tu comprends c'est plus
sympa quand même l'allaitement
non on n'a pas un joker comme ça on
voulait pas allaiter alors vous avez lu
françoise dolto
non j'ai écouté un petit peu ses
interviews mais voilà pas vraiment le
fait que ce soit la mère de carlos ça
vous vous vous dites dans le fond il a
l'air heureux il est content non vous
avez acheté son doudou en double dès
fois qu'il le perde le petit ruben non
on me l'a conseillé en revanche la wii
mais pour l'instant il n'a pas choisi
encore lequel ils préfèrent les tout
petits lits qui les paie 50 cm encore
mais bon la naissance c'était le plus
beau jour de votre vie j'imagine mais
depuis ça se dégrade un peu quand même
non pour l'instant ça va
il fait des petits sourires donc même si
on me dit qu'il ne sourit pas moi je
suis contente
là il devient tout rouge
c'est une catastrophe moi je suis
entièrement paniqué quand il devient
rouge me dis oh là là mais qu'est ce qui
fait un tabac ce qui va péter une veine
dans le sahara vos jeux le mas vous avez
déjà eu envie de le gifler quand il
pleure pas encore mais un mois après
j'ai fait un gamin à 15 jours y a pas de
contre-indication dur et long maintenant
vous avez le petit vous pensé quitter le
papa bientôt non je pensais qu'il allait
me demande un mariage s'est toujours pas
vraiment les tétines à trois vitesses
vous connaissez oui c'est bien mais
c'est pas mal à vous et c'est que vous
êtes complètement vous dormez avec votre
enfant parce que c'est magnifique de
dormir etc son enfant non j'ai peur
d'écraser comme je bouge j'ai peur de me
retourner de l'écraser et voulant gevo
vibre nev
je fais tout des trois petits cochons
c'est très bien c'est très touchant en
fait j'en voulais un autre lâcher tout
de suite là ouais voilà non n'attendent
pas l'argent mais à choisir entre le
bébé le césar vous auriez préféré un
autre césar non non préférez le bébé
ouais penser que maman c'est le rôle de
votre vie quoi non plus mais mais chez
mais non mais c'est bien je suis très
compagne comme ça vous êtes préparés
comment pour ce rôle et ne suis pas du
tout préparés en fait voilà j'ai appris
j'étais enceinte j'ai dit bon bah voilà
vous êtes tombée enceinte
combien de prise j'étais en chine
c'est la première fois qu'une poignée du
poids pour beaucoup ça bah ouais 11
ouais j'ai perdu là j'ai droit à un
deuxième joker enfin
pour l'accouchement vous n'êtes pas été
doublé c'est vraiment vous ouais c'était
dur ben non je vais non non non
maintenant il ya la péridurale il
souffre plus qu'est ce que c'est au rôle
vous a apporté de plus que les
précédents et ben j'en prends pour vingt
ans trente quarante cinquante noms 6
mais là c'est bien parce qu'il décide à
ma place là aussi ça me va bien moi
comme titulaire voilà quelle europe vous
voulez pour votre enfant
l'europe du oui où l'europe du nom
n'aura pas trop pour l'instant on est
resté bloqué à la une a tout de suite
mais non moi je rejoindrai un petit peu
ce que j'ai entendu dire j'ai
l'impression qu'on a commencé un travail
qui - a priori me plaît mais donc
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à améliorer mais
pourquoi pas essayer de sauver ce qu'on
a déjà commencé à construire le taxi est
en retard je n'arrivais en fait j'ai pas
entendu tout ça c'est l'histoire de taxi
[Musique]
je voulais tirer une carte jaune et noir
s'est créé c'est très intéressant mais
line
voila voila quoi non voiture une autre
c'est quoi vous devez dire du bien de
bataille et fontaine et alors il faut le
faire
bah qu'est ce que je vais dire eh ben
ils sont à part qu'ils sont formidables
bataille et fontaine et qui sont très
inventif et qu'est ce que je pourrais
dire voilà j'ai bien indigne surtout
voilà pas oui voilà ça c'est bien digne
et voilà je tire une autre carte
autrement suggéré une caméra d'or bon
alors ça va être vite fait vous devez
donner tout l'argent que vous avez sur
vous à une oeuvre caritative 1 je dois
avoir quoi je sais pas j'ai si j'en sais
rien je vais avoir 50 euros c'est que la
regardez regardez sur moi lamanon agents
n'est pas celle en valeur
ah bah ouais combien à 50 euros ouais
vous les donner à qui jacques crozemarie
mais il touche plus rien je peux pas
croire qu'il vit encore sur les
dividendes
non je lui donnerais à qui où est la
recherche pour le cancer contre le
cancer là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
antonio je vais vous laisser filer et
merci
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant j'accueille jean
christophe rufin
agresseurs de cambon soir vous êtes
médecin pionniers de l'action
humanitaire
et puis en plus vous écrivez vous avez
écrit l'abyssin vous avez écrit rouge
brésil qui a eu le prix goncourt en en
2001 globalia la dernière fois qu'il est
venu c'était pour globalia est
aujourd'hui la seule amende chez
gallimard en la salamandre selon la
tradition ne craint pas le feu et c'est
vrai que votre livre c'est l'histoire
d'une femme qui quitte la france pour la
chaleur du brésil et qui va s'y brûler
c'est une histoire vraie d'abord c'est
l'histoire que kick-ass est fréquent
d'un d'une femme qui française qui a une
vie assez banal et puis qui part dans un
pays chaud attirer justement par sa part
1 par la chaleur pour fait qu'elle va
être en vacances qu'elle avoir une
copine etc et qui met le doigt de fès
d'engrenages elle va rencontrer un
garçon sur la plage et puis petit à
petit se trouvaient deux prises dans
cette dans cette passion qui va lui
faire changer de monde ou hamon voilà
l'histoire d'une française donc de 46
ans qui a été mariée un mariage sans
sang beaucoup de sang ce qui a eu un
divorce assez rapide qui se noie dans le
travail
effectivement elle part en vacances au
brésil elle tombe sur un gigolo sur la
plage est là et là effectivement c'est
le drame de sa vie
ainsi une histoire qui vous a été
racontée par le consul de france à
arrecife ca le brésil
ils y arrivent souvent ce genre
d'histoires simplement là celle-là cette
histoire là est particulièrement dur
puisque finalement cet amour elles
veulent vivre complètement mais à la fin
il va être aussi complètement rejetés et
malgré tout elle va continuer à
haha ça se bat pour ce garçon dont on
sait c'est une histoire extrêmement des
mois je quand on m'a raconté cette
histoire j'ai trouvé tellement tellement
horrible que cette manière que j'ai pas
pu et j'ai pas pu l'écrire mais je les
gardais dans la tête pendant des années
et je pars elle mais elle m'aimait
ressorti vont d'abord comme une espèce
de petite nouvelle et puis elle a pris
de l'ampleur et elle est devenue un
livre complet
j'ai toujours écrit des livres sur la
rencontre des civilisations sur le nord
sud vendant dans le passé puis aussi
aussi dans le futur finalement et que
global hier c'était l'évolution de ces
rencontres le tiers-monde salaces et là
c'est le tiers monde et l'europe où les
pays disons développés pays riches vue à
travers une petite scène qu elle scelle
la scène d'une passion des femmes et
d'un homme qui chacun finalement
représentent ces mondes puisque elle
part en europe hors france elle n'est
pas très riche mais quand elle arrive au
brésil évidemment elle est beaucoup plus
riche que tous les gens qui sont autour
tant qu'elles véhiculent fait dans tout
ce qu'on est nous c'est à dire la
prospérité la richesse est bon et lui il
est théoriquement pauvres mais en fait
il ya toute une richesse aussi en lui
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui la tire c'est la
musique qui a la une culture et tout ça
et et finalement c'est ça c'était qu'ils
vont vivre tous les deux
quelque chose qui est finalement la
planète c'est la planète d'aujourd'hui
qui vivent dans leur dans l'eure dans
leur intimité c'est ce déchirement de
ces demandes dont l'un possède toute la
prospérité mais a perdu quand même sa
chaleur de cette façon et beaucoup de sa
culture pas ça pour pour boehringer mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya cette dimension là
c'est à dire qu'on va chercher en
afrique on va chercher au brésil quelque
chose qu'on a plus tu as de manière donc
on est à la fois riches et pauvres qu'on
est pauvre quand on vient c'est payé la
pauvre de quelque chose qu'on trouve
là-bas se termine très mal parce qu en
fait à un moment il veut acheter un bar
il l'envoie en france et le vend son
appartement elle touche ses indemnités
de licenciement
quand quand lui la retrouve en fait le
bar a déjà été vendus mais il garde
quand même le pognon et puis après pour
elle c'est une déchéance terrible quoi à
dire qu'elle coupe tout les ponts cercle
vente où est elle
donne tout c'est à dire qu'elle donne
elle commence par payer un petit peu
comme les repas les achats puis après
elle donne elle donne parce qu'elle se
rend compte qu'il ya une espèce de dette
bon point qu'on a et ça aussi ça nous
renvoie à nous durabilité ouais sauf que
si vous voulez ce qui est intéressant
c'est que là aussi c'est à fois elle se
prive de tout et en même temps elle
acquiert quelque chose pourquoi parce
qu'elle devient une partie de ce monde
justement qu'elle voulait connaître
cirque abandonné le dit pardon quand
elle voit des touristes dans la ruelle
c'est ce qu'ils vont se faire dévaliser
pourquoi parce qu'elle fait partie des
autres déjà les halal coup d'oeil de la
bande c'est qu'elle sait le fait pas
elle même quoi qu'elle va est entré
dedans mais elle est passée de l'autre
côté est passé de côté leur avons fait
complètement la tradition évidemment il
va le payer très cher alors des scènes
absolument terrible joie le voient
passer sur sa moto avec une fille
derrière derrière lui qui le sert comme
ça elle lui a acheté une montre de
plongée à lui donne quand même il on
parle pas et puis si la déchéance quoi
elle se retrouve
oui c'est ce que je veux dire elle s'en
rend compte que ce qu'elle à ce qu'elle
a voulu apporter peut pas tellement lui
donner parce que bon je veux dire lui
l'a utilisé de cette manière merci ça
qu'un mois c'est ça qui m'intéresse et
self
c'est la question de savoir finalement
si l'amour a besoin de l'aide de l'objet
qu'on aime quand l'objet qu'on aime
quand la personne qu'on aime se retourne
contre vous et vous et vous et vous ni
comme l ailier lcr parce qu' il va là il
va la rejeter complètement un poids
qu'on peut pas imaginer et et malgré
tout il va continuer de l'aimer c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
évidemment ce qu'elle aura découvert
dans ce parcours c'est que l'amour n'a
pas forcément besoin de celui ou de
celle sur qui porte quoi il n'ya pas de
découvertes plus à la fois plus tragique
et plus et plus belle parce que
finalement c'est ça veut dire que ça on
dirait que les empereurs romains c'est
il y avait il ya vait augustine certain
nombre de caractères gens dit aux gars
et félix le fait de dire que le bonheur
est un attribut de la souveraineté
bonheur c'est quelque chose qu'on a en
soi et qui dépend pas des autres et
l'amour c'est pareil aussi c'était
quelque chose qu'on est capable de
donner ou pas et elle va se découvrir
capable de le donner mais elle va le
payer cher très cher ça vous intéresse
moi je viens de finir un script qui est
un peu sur ce sujet là donc enfin que
même pratiquement sur ce sujet-là
différentes situations mais j'adore ce
genre de secret je vois un film
formidable ça avec josiane balasko un
bouquin qui s'appelle la client est
vraiment pas loin s'intéressent bien sûr
ses brûlures ouais bien sûr mais c'est
intéressant aussi de dire que que
l'amour peut-être pas besoin de de
l'objet mais c'est dur à une ici les
gens sont toujours en train de vous dire
je suis seul se dire ah parce que j'ai
pas trouvé quelqu'un qui m'aime mais
problème c'est que c'est surtout la
capacité nous des mecs on a perdu un
plein c'est à l'aider elle trouve
qu'elle avait la trouille mais sauf que
il va à la rejette mais ça c'est fait
penser qu'un homme dans une situation
telle c'est intéressant que vous ayez
fait que ce soit l'histoire d'une femme
parce que ça change d'un schéma habituel
ou est un homme aurait aura été jusqu'au
bout de cette déchéance par amour je
vois pas non je crois pas
or les grands récits romanesques avec
les hommes détruit bâle en amérique le
problème c'est que quand on les
relations la prostitution de sa fait que
les relations d'argent entre hommes et
femmes sont quand même beaucoup plus
banalisée codifié manière donc on peut
rester un peu extérieur à ça alors
qu'une femme ait pas est pas préparé à
ça donc à partir du moment où il ya des
relations d'argent ou des trucs qu'ils
pas et qui se passe c'est pas naturel
pour une enquête au début elles se
jettent à dire tous et très confortable
mais je suis métisse très bien après
elle découvre la misère la découvrit vie
elle va voir un faval va voir où il vit
elle se dit mais finalement si je paye
du pay pal c'est parce que finalement
une réparation formidable fausse donne
tout une superbe et ex trader fou je
donne tout je donne tout mais c'est
finalement j'ai tout est là rien ce mec
est finalement elle donne tout et là
elle se rend compte que je veux dire
c'est tout à fait autre chose qui se
passe dans très clair que la richesse
n'est pas du côté qu'on croit de cette
manière qu'elle la richesse celle là
elle elle l'a perdue mais elle l'a
trouvée aussi d'autres autrement je sais
pas si je raccroche à 6
la salamandre c'est
c'est m
jacquet lisa stansfield
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir
bizarre vous êtes vous est redevenue
brune
oui je n'ai jamais été blonde je me
regarde dans le miroir je m'excuse c'est
pas moi c'est qui ça non j'étais pas
votre couleur blonde avoue être mieux
comme ça quand même vraiment comme ça on
vous reconnais moi je me souviens de
vous vous souvenez comme vie au palace
dans lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
vous aviez un petit accroche-coeurs
comme ça sur le front à l'époque deux ça
ça fait longtemps
mais oui pour ceux qui n'étaient pas au
palace avec nous en 89
lisa stansfield c'est ça
ouais
mathé
le valais
le maire
m
attention nous t'aimons
[Musique]
doué
ap
mais romero
bravo
[Musique]
thématique coalisation
nous en sommes là
l'âme de l'asean anglaise américain
henri danse et hadoop il était comme ça
va me dit qu'on aurait un chien arrière
des cagnottes
allez faites ça beau morceau alors vous
revenez avec un nouvel album s'appelle
the movement
et pourquoi avoir attendu trois ans ah
oui j'ai entendu dire et tout le monde
me parle à chaque fois d'un come-back
les deux lycéens suivent donc je fais
des combats depuis 16 ans chaque fois
que je serai album et je crois que je
préfère de mettre sur le marché qu'un
album dont je suis vraiment fier tous
les trois ans
plutôt que de lancer un album médiocre
pas tous des ans je crois que je ne
serai pas encore là si j'avais fait ça
très bien
alors vous avez travaillé avec le fameux
trésor homme qui est le producteur de ta
tu de frankie goes to hollywood style et
l'album bretonne à l'album est vachement
bien le premier single s'appelle traite
moi comme une femme ce 8 mai l'accueil
ou oman
m
non
à tous
me
vous allez regarder votre caméra nos
cadiot caméra et vous dit simplement je
sais magnéto serge et magnéto serge
magnéto serge
tu es
tombola
je suis là comme avec celle d'un homme
les visages sont alors la chanson
s'appelle treat me like a woman
traitement comme une femme est ce que ça
veut dire que vous n'aimez pas les
hommes vulnérables
pour moi c'est l'histoire d'une femme
mûre qui dit ne me traitez plus comme si
j'avais 22 ou 23 ans les règles du jeu a
changé pour me sortir
je n'ai pas envie d'aller au mcdonald's
et qu'ensuite tu ailles voir tes amis et
du football est réellement changé ouais
alors dans le clip vous êtes dans les
bras d'une femme habillée en sommes à un
moment est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé
en vrai non non on va voir vous en êtes
en tant que femme on va faire une
interview fait ou à faire alors puisque
vous voulez qu'on vous traite comme une
femme on va voir donc vous vous en êtes
est-ce que vous avez une meilleure
copine qui vous racontez vos histoires
tous les soirs au téléphone j'ai une
meilleure copine à qui je dis presque
tous au téléphone tenir un journal
intime fait ou à faire je tiens journal
tombée amoureuse d'un gros connard fait
ou à faire toute femme l'a fait un jour
dans sa vie faire une soirée pyjama avec
des copines fait ou à faire ça j'essaie
se goinfraient avec des glaces après une
rupture fait ou à faire c'est tricher en
mettant du coton dans son soutien-gorge
fait ou à faire bien sûr coucher avec un
inconnu dans les toilettes d'une boîte
de nuit fait ou à faire à temps jamais
ça jamais fait hurler j'ai rien à me
mettre devant une penderie plein fairway
faire
oui tous les jours avoir un accident en
conduisant la voiture de votre copain
fait ou à faire j'ai fait ça aussi un
chai avec une femme frais ou à faire
j'ai déjà l'ex partager un lit avec une
femme mais mais jamais de relation
sexuelle avec une femme non se faire
tromper par son mec fait ou affaire n y
crois pas non plus coucher avec un mec
carrément qu'on mettrait très beaux
faits ou à faire j'ai fait ça sortir
avec un homme marié fait ou affaires
n'ont jamais fait la chirurgie
esthétique fait ou à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais peut-être et dans 10 ans j'y
penserai poser nue dans un magazine fait
ou à faire non mais je me suis montré
dans des clips vidéos n'ont donc jamais
été photographiée nue mais on m'a filmée
nue sortir sans sous vêtements parce que
c'est agréable fait ou à faire c'est
avoir un ami gay pour faire du shopping
fait ou à faire c'est remettre la
bretelle de son soutien-gorge mine de
rien mais parce que ça excite les mecs
fait ou à faire j'ai jamais su que ça
rendait les hommes fous je fais tout le
temps dire est son meilleur ami
qu'on veut pas gâcher une telle amitié
en cochons ensemble fait ou à faire je
les dis va te coucher ensemble on est
toujours ensemble une aventure avec un
français pendant une émission de
télévision fait aux affaires
la avoir plusieurs orgasmes à la suite
fait ou affaire donne maintenant une
autre fois lui oui
nous à merci quelquefois comme et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jacques à
bonsoir ça va ça va bien alors été
avocat vous avez déjà plaidé nu sous la
robe
c'est assez difficile parce que en bas
de la robe en voile et chaussettes et
puis les chaussures que ça serait un peu
difficile mais déjà sans pantalon
dessous l'europe va essayer déjà je ne
répondrai pas à cette question parce que
le bâtonnier regarde l'émission donc le
bâtonnier c'est papa la première
sanction qu'on peut recevoir en tant
qu'avocat c'est l'admonestation paternel
donc c'est tout un symbole vérifiez la
mini jupe pour plaider sa n'est pas
encore autorisé thierry abord vous raser
les gens voulaient je veux les montres
épiler bien donc c'est un avocat vous
est aussi écrivain mais déjà publié
trois romans est aujourd'hui publié les
10 gros blancs chez fayard en le pitch
est assez simple ça se passe à l'île
moustique et cette île paradisiaque pour
milliardaires des caraïbes est un tueur
en série s'en prend aux stars de la pop
et du rock
à commencer par mick jagger et david
bowie alors ça ressemble un peu à dix
petits c'est un peu agatha
christie quoi c'est d'ailleurs ce avoué
dans le bouquin c'est à vous et ils ont
même un grave problème dans le bouquin
c'est qu'au bout d'un moment ils
finissent par s'en rendre compte il faut
bien se rendre compte que d'abord ils
sont tous complètement analphabètes
donc ce sont des stars du rock mais des
stars du rock qui choisissent d'aller à
l'île moustique qu'est l'île la plus
ravagée de toutes les caraïbes s'est
tous les inconvénients des antilles
aucun des avantages il faut déjà avoir
ils ont un bagage culturel
parfois un peu limité ce qui fait qu'il
ya pas de livres il n'y a pas de
bibliothèque donc mais quand même ça
leur rappelle quelque chose parce
qu'elles éclatent à christie les
britanniques comme et c'est donc ils
finissent par faire le rapprochement
problème personne admis bio tech
personnels livres
il va leur falloir un moment un autre
met la main sur les idées petits
pour connaître qui est l'assassin
ce qui est très drôle c'est que l' arme
du crime ce sont les moustiques alors
que lille a été désinsectiser à une
époque
c'est le grand retour des moustiques à
l'aller le moustique c'est ça l'histoire
oui on peut le résumer comme sans
l'atteindre finalement que les
moustiques reprennent possession de leur
dollar il les moustiques se venge mais
ce ne sont pas les seuls coupables alors
une bonne description du lieu vous
connaissez les moustiques à bas l'idée
m'est venue lors d'un séjour à l'île
moustique où j'écrivais un autre livre
et je dois dire que j'ai eu un choc
culturel
ça s'appelle une grosse déception mais
n'y a pas de vie locale il ya rien n'y a
pas de marché il n'y a pas de absolument
registre il ya ceux des villas pour
milliardaires il n'y a pas un seul
pêcheur créole il n'y a pas un seul
marché de fruits et légumes sympa il ya
absolument rien il ya juste un moment
mick jagger qui est passé faisant de la
course en sac devant moi et alors là
j'avoue que tout ce que je pensais des
rolling stones s'est effondré d'un seul
coup et ce monsieur musique quand même
sept îles dans laquelle je commence à
m'emmerder sérieusement depuis
trois-quatre jours méritait que on l'a
brocarde dans un polar un petit peu un
petit peu ironique mais vous avez du
pognon parce que le côté même si c'est
un local assez pourri ça vaut quand même
du fric tous les jours à ça coûte une
fortune c'est même ce que je raconte
dans le bouquet c'est l'hôtel c'est le
deux étoiles le plus cher de la planète
à peu près
non il s'avère que j'ai quelques clients
people quelques clients vip qu'au bout
de ma vie tu es quand j'ai la musique il
taquine et on a envie d'écrire un livre
ouais non c'est une il faut le dire qui
a été lancé par margaret la soeur de la
reine d'angleterre qui est et qui était
assez huppé dans les années 60 70 et
aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins
fréquentées ici ah si si si c'est très
fréquentée bon margaret
est passé à passer l'armé à gauche il ya
à peu près deux ans environ elle avait
lancé la mode mais il ya eu et je les
met tous en scène david bowie elton john
mick jagger lou reed grosse déception
laurie dans l'arène sur l'île moustique
laurie de laurie anderson
rod stewart johnson denzel washington y
est même j'ai vu que bryan adams et ya
quinze jours ou quelque chose comme ça
venait de même d'acheter
lui aussi une maison et les moustiques
ce qui montre bien encore une fois le
niveau éducatif générale de l'ensemble
de l'île paradis fiscal non ça n'est
même pas paraître fiscales donc il faut
vraiment avoir un très mauvais
raisonnement
alors voilà l'enquêté menée par un
dénommé prospère boniface un médecin
guadeloupéen lettrés et puis voilà ça
continue après bowie après jeger c'est
elton john key qui était assassiné puis
voilà je vais pas raconter d'histoires
examen puisque c'est un peu là alors il
ya des précisions sur la vie sexuelle de
lille aussi c'est vraiment un coaccusé
lupanar quand même hein forcément c'est
un caillou qui fait 3 km sur deux on a
300 milliardaires qui s'emmerde à
l'invers de temps qu'est ce qu'ils font
quand ils ne lisent pas quand ils ont
regardé pour la quatrième fois un film
sur un écran plasma qui fait 5 mètres
sur 3 et qu'en plus on peut pas se
baigner parce qu'il ya des courants
hallucinant et c'est donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils font bain
ils font ils font ce qu'il reste à faire
en l'air il sent voilà donc la piste
sexuelle est une piste importante qu'ils
ont c'est dans l'histoire du rock que
bas les liaisons entre les uns et les
autres ont existé voilà c'est un petit
livre très charmant les 10 gros blanc
d'emmanuel pierrât chez fayard alors
comme vous êtes avocat
on vous faire une interview 4 conscience
[Musique]
avez vous déjà trouvé que le
réquisitoire du procureur en face de
vous était trop gentil
oui ça m'est arrivé une fois j'étais
persuadé avec mon client qu'on n'allait
pas pouvoir y échapper il était coupable
donc on demande l indulgence et puis le
procureur était tellement nul qu'il
n'avait pas lu le dossier il a demandé
l'acquittement plus donc on s'est
retrouvé comme des cons et finalement
ben on a gagné en quelque sorte mieux
que ce qu'on espérait est-ce que vous
avez déjà fait innocente et un coupable
ça pourrait même être déjà arrivé
thierry mais j'attends vous me confiez
votre dossier parce que ça ferait
vraiment une jurisprudence
si vous êtes déjà fait condamner un
innocent je vous répondrai pas parce que
je vous donnerai pas de nom parce que ça
permettrait d'obtenir une révision du
procès vous avez déjà été embêté quand
un coup pas vous a demandé de le
défendre
si un coupable me demande de le défendre
et que ça m'embête je vais me dessaisir
du dossier parce que ça veut dire que ma
conscience va l'emporter sur un mental
en un éventuel d'avocats et donc je vais
plaider comme un naze
donc ça n'a aucun intérêt vous a fait
exprès d'être mauvais dans un procès
pour le perdre on n'arrive pas à être
mauvais même le morceau exprès
comment ils se la pètent s'émousse vous
avez déjà pensé qu'un de vos clients
méritait une peine plus lourde que celle
qu'il a reçus oui le jour où il y en a
un qui m'a filé un chèque en bois
est ce que vous êtes déjà trouvé la
justice injuste la justice les par
définition juste c'est l'institution
judiciaire qui est injuste il ya une
grande nuance entre les deux villages
entiers dans un tribunal la parole est
libre
vous êtes déjà été plaidé pour faire
sauter un pv
oui une seule fois c'était les miens 2
j'ai été condamné j'en ai pris plein la
figure donc les cordonniers sont
vraiment les plus mal chaussés
j'ai perdu beaucoup de poids est ce que
vous êtes jaloux du mal à croiser le
regard des familles d'une de victimes
que vous avez défendu
oui parce qu'on a beau se prendre pour
robocop qui à un moment où la cuirasse
elle s'effrite un peu quand même
voulzy a été heureux d'être détesté
voilà quand j'ai fait condamner ou quand
j'ai gagné contre des ordures
ouais tu as trouvé ça agréable d'être
détesté par eux vous êtes déjà détesté
être heureux vous voyez quand le client
là encore ne me paye pas ou alors qu'ils
oublient de me remercie alors que son
dossier était pas gagné d avance
pensez que vous êtes un bon avocat
si je pensais que j'étais mauvais avocat
je crois que je changerais de métier
le test
bon jouer avec nous j'accueille
clémentine célarié et son fils avant
m
bonsoir à nu alors c'est un bonus
clémentine oui c'est mon fils a bravé
ben oui ça c'est le petit poucet grand
1er mai 1 depuis un an vous êtes sur
scène avec toute la famille ça s'appelle
mon cabaret ouais merci on va pas en
parler pas pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
est vraiment venu pour pour comment dire
pour ce pur pour un truc pour lequel on
s'est retrouvés réunis tous les deux
pour le sida en fait et en fait on a
fait de la musique tous les deux on a
fait un titre ensemble pour eux pour le
pas ce que parce qu'on a voulu faire un
espèce de baiser collectif
tiens j'ai voulu simplement démultiplier
ce baiser que j'avais donnée à cet homme
qui s'appelle patrice jeanniot il ya 11
ans dans un sidaction 10 à 11 ans le
premier et je voulais le démultiplier
parce que comme ça il tu vois j'ai pensé
qu'il serait plus fort bon alors c'est
un soir j'étais dans une émission chez
cauet comme sage et g10 comme ça qu'ils
feraient qui s'embrassent ray sur la
bouche le l'idée de s'embrasser sur un
cd solidarité voilà avec un séropositif
et une personnes séropositive ou
séropositives eux et à ce moment là tout
le monde a dit j'ai dit par exemple
c'est comme si on demande est là tu vois
qu'ils seraient là et puis plein de gens
devaient la main et moi je me suis dit
tiens on va faire ce clip
après ça a été une galère sans nom mais
vraiment sans nom de faire ça parce
qu'en fait une personne sur deux a peur
donc je suis très heureuse qu'on l'ait
fait parce que contrairement aux idées
reçues c'est un truc c'est la moindre
des choses mais en même temps il ya
plein de gens qui ont peur bon de faire
ça donc on l'a fait grâce à une femme et
sa clique bac raf
il ya eu toute une équipe de gens qui se
sont mises autour avec nous et puis à
bras je lui dis bon endroit il faut
qu'on se bouge le cul et on a fait un
titre tous les deux et en fait on a fait
ça pour le sidaction est donc c'était il
ya eu çà a été collectivement brichart
aurait pu être là bas on n'a pas ce que
ça s'est fait très vite dans l'urgence a
eu la région non mais c'était important
parce que
comment dire c'est en même temps c'est
une goutte d'eau quoi on va voir à quoi
ça ressemble crois que c'est le plus
simple tu va regarder ta caméra
clémentine c'est lequel avec les rouges
de dire magnéto serge magnéto serge
comme il est en effet il ya une bêtise
que j'ai que j'ai envie de faire depuis
depuis depuis tout à l'heure
parce qu'après tout on est là pour pour
s'unir les séropositifs n'est pas
séropositif les homosexuels et pas
homosexuel et c'est un truc tout bête
mais j'ai envie de t'embrasser de
l'échiquier est derrière moi
[Musique]
ce
le savait
il aussi
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du prix
si le sida
c'est toi non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fa c'est en fait c'est juste un truc
bête c'est que ce clip qui dure trois
minutes et demie ouais
et pendant ce clip il ya vingt personnes
qui meurent du sida
un jour je veux dire ça mais c'est c'est
en fait ces espèces de de choses dedans
fin de médicaments qui est la
trithérapie a fait croire que c'était
fini tu vois ce qui fait que ça s'est
arrêté c'était plus à la mode le sida
donc en fait c'est grave
il ya plein de gens qui meurent de ça et
il ya toujours pas de vaccin et voilà
donc c'est en fait c'est un appel aux
dons il faut faire le 110 ha oui c'est
210 500 disent qu'il faut faire pour
pour qu'ils aient de l'argent quoi c'est
ça va commencer le week-end du sidaction
tu sais le 1er 2 3 avril et voilà voilà
c'était juste ça donc bien tu as la
multiplier qu'on jette
bien
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille pedro winter alors
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous connaissez le
principe du blind test je veux
l'interprète que ce soit un chanteur une
chanteuse un groupe je ne veux pas le
titre je veux que l'interprète est ce
que vous êtes prêt de ces frais manuel
attention est chargé près attention et
drôle
[Musique]
d
à bord
à richard vacances et l'équipe c'est
l'équipe de richard tu m'as tu marques
et pour en sortir tu vas y arriver jeudi
à lens
[Musique]
un partout 1 pour l'équipe de richard 1
pour l'équipe de clémentine il est bon
ton fils lors tient évidemment pedro
non
j'ai compris j'ai vibré ainsi j'ai
compris c'est pas ça c'est que j'en
tombe à ce qu'ils disent
pas tant que ça et là des contenus sur
michael non
bah
[Musique]
deux bars ont marre vos cv à l'epo à
pedro
[Musique]
michael ce crime michael jackson ce
crime
à la gare jackson
[Musique]
paris
on continue pedro déjà ça non
[Musique]
mcgurk ou non
non
mado bonnet cinéma
voilà
c'est fait
ah oui
le haut
wayne wonder
[Applaudissements]
tu as
tu as bien fait de l'amener des bons
trucs dans la bagarre a tout de suite
fait droit à quoi donne un rouge
madonna
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la france
alléchant
c'est vrai bien bravo bravo si si c'est
un peu comme la bourse le blind shear
quand tu vous regarde la bouche ces
contrats sont bien les vaincus rend tous
les sens
là c'est pareil mais y'en a qui gagnent
en a qui perdent chacun c'est comme à la
bourse d'alors et au départ andrew
sisters
[Musique]
c'est un peu
maintenant
cela dit avant lui plaît non
et au départ
andrew sisters
c
dit non
aussi ça veut dire il a dit c'est un
drame poignant
[Applaudissements]
en corse ll rappelle l'intérêt renaît
rappelle t on
[Musique]
non
c'est fait 3 pour l'équipe de barrage et
6 pour l'équipe de clémentine
[Applaudissements]
ces noms ne pas laisser m
mais ça semble presque
m
[Musique]
lenny kravitz
les deux
je sais du côté
voilà encore j'avais d'euros - a
oui
dis moi qui tu es
[Musique]
c'est à l'issue du plach équipe c'est
l'équipe de clémentine qui gagne cette
fois
cette fois 24 et maintenant on arrive
chacun pour sa gueule donc là ya plus d
équipes chacun joue pour soi rebonds
c'est le libéralisme c'est le rouillé
c'est le oui c'est le chacun pour soi
maintenant y aménageant alors
[Musique]
m
or
serge july exige aniston triplé on va
voir
[Musique]
quand tu la dit quand je sais que j'aime
pas à côté de la plaque non dangereux si
elle joue peu à quoi normalement il ya
des matins pour aller c'est normal quand
j'entends pas donc je suis et j'y crois
moi à toi
[Musique]
chanson reprise par jimi hendrix mon
cher ami all along the watchtower dylan
à l'origine pedro
[Musique]
l'aurait-on fils il explose tout le
monde l'attend elle est trop fort l'un
vraiment vas-y
[Musique]
oui oui ouais alors
là haut
non
voilà donc à l'issue du chacun pour sa
gueule c'est abraham qui gagne à
bordeaux
et vous avez un temps c'est un toit
c'est ton âge tu veux dire non c'est pas
ça y'a rien foutu à l'école c'était tu
mens lampard mariah carey
l'album s'appelle des mecs
les jeunes mimi qui sur le terrain
[Musique]
julie des personnes chez richard baker
mais j'ai des filles
jeannot la bande originale before sunset
chance et d entre eux deux
merci est braqué avec nous richard
bohringer multifonctions du désir jette
à marier en blanc
syvie testud léman bleu d'alain corneau
avec sylvie testud siagi le fait sorti
le 23 mars
jean-christophe
la salamandre chez gallimard visage
celui d'album chapelle de mama
[Musique]
emmanuel pierrât les tigres blancs c'est
chez fayard clémentine célarié ron du
sidaction 2005 du 1er au 3 avril
l'appel aux dons puis leçon d'histoire
et le brent est merci ses ordinateurs
le dvd vicens kitchen la pomme d'apple
c'était vraiment l'enfer
rendez vous la semaine prochaine merci
de votre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
ah ah
[Musique]
ouais
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu